Vhle prezence je přítomen dostatečný počet členů, aby se zastupitelstvo mohlo usnášet.
Omluvení s dnešním zastupitelstva jsou pan Ivo Mitáček, paní Jana Bazilová,
pan Pavel Sekula, pan Česmír Vančura.
Dřívější odchod nahlásil pan Tomáš Dudák.
V distanční účastí se nepřihlásil žádný členu zastupitelstva.
K ověření zápisu z dnešního zasedání určují titočně zastupitelstva
to pana Romana Kaňovského a pana Stanislava Skálu.
Zápis z 25. zasedání zastupitelstva z dnešního zase 26. března
byl bez připomínek ověřen a podepsán.
Vážení členy zastupitelstva, nyní prosím provedeme volbu návrové komise.
Do návrové komise navrhuji titočení zastupitelstva,
a to jako předsedkyní paní Michalu Blahovou a jako členy paní Zuzanu Fischerovou
a pana Vřetislava Prchala. Máte někdo k tomuto návrhu připomínky?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím pojďme hlasovat o návrové komisi tak,
jak jsem ji přednesl.
Pro 34. návrhová komise byla zkválena.
Vzhledem k tomu, že zjednání zastupitelstva města z dnešního zase 26. března
na audiovizuální záznam, který je online přenášen.
Žádám všechny diskutující s ohledem na příslušná zákona
a ustanovení o ochraně osobních údajů, aby ve svých projevech neuváděli,
po případě minimalizovali používání osobních údajů
a pouze případně uvedli odkaz na tento údaj v materiálech.
Jako další bod dnešního zastupitelstva je vystoupení občanů
a tímto předávám slovo panu Pémníkovi.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Vážené dámy, vážení pánové, dle jednacího řadu zastupitelstva města Zlína
odstavce 7 článku 7 odstavce 2 vystoupení občanů sdělují,
že máme celkem 3 přihlášky z veřejnosti k vystoupení občanů k tomuto bodu.
Prvním vystupujícím je pan Pavel Šimeček, jenom upozorňuji,
že maximální délka vystoupení jsou 4 minuty. Prosím, máte slovo.
Dobrý den, pane primátore. Dobrý den, vážené zastupitelstvo.
Přicházím k vám kvůli události, která se mě stala zhruba před měsícem,
která mě překvapila, trochu zaskočila a přišla mě líto.
Chtěl jsem svým elektrokolem jet snědajím pindula a nahoru.
Pokoušel jsem se nastoupit na obecinách, kde mi bylo řidičem vzděleno,
že elektrokola se, že zákaz přepraví, že se nepřepravují.
Tento zákaz mě poněkud překvapil, jak už jsem řekl,
a vytanula mi na mysli událost zhruba před setmi lety,
kdy jsem si své elektrokolo pořizoval a to mi bylo 62 let.
Řekl jsem si, že se poradím o této koupi se svým synovcem,
který je mnohonásobný mistr republiky v silnější cyklistice,
tak proč nejít za odborníkem.
A můj synovec říkal elektrokola, nemám je rád.
Říkám, proč se ti provedla?
No tak si představ tu situaci, kdy já,
profesionální cyklista v tréninku si vědu,
jedu dlouhý kopec a předjede mě nějaký nýmand na elektrokole.
To naštve, že?
Tak jsme se souhlasili, že to musí naštvat,
společně jsme se tomu zasmáli.
No a já jsem si tuto situaci aplikoval na zlínské poměry,
kdy někdo mladý, krásný a možná i s dostatečnými rozhodovacími pravomocemi
si taky vyjel na elektrokole a předjel ho,
dědek jako já, nebo postarší paní.
No tak to samozřejmě naštve.
Já vám taky šlápnu na kuří oko.
Ale jak to udělat?
Nemůžu to svéc na to, že mě to ponížilo.
Dobrá, bezpečnost se dneska sklonuje ve všech pádech.
Má to baterii, je to nebezpečné.
Vyřadíme vás z MHD.
Je to pěkné.
Já sice souhlasím s tím, že určité nebezpečí to představuje.
Ovšem já vám navrhuji teda v tom případě další věci,
které jsou stejně nebezpečné, ba přímo nebezpečnější
a musíte je také aplikovat.
První věc je mobilní telefony, tablety.
Taky občas tyto baterie vybuchnou a zkusují požár.
Vyloučit z MHD, je to jasné.
Další věc je podstatně závažnější.
Představte si, že elektromobil vjede do parkovacího domu
na dlouhé ulici, několika patrového,
anebo vjede do krytého parkoviště pod kongresovým centrem.
Jeho baterie najednou začne hořet.
Představte si tuto eventuální situaci a stává se to.
Tak nám zhoří celé kongresové centrum,
proč se tato baterie nedá uhasit,
anebo nám zhoří parkoviště na dlouhé ulici
i s přilehlými obchody.
Nepředstavitelné zakázat.
Třetí věc, kterou bych rád připomněl,
vím, že před pár lety
dopravní společnost pořídila
trolejbusy, autobusy
bateriovým pohonem.
Náklad samozřejmě desítky milionů.
Nicméně,
tato baterie je
stokrát těžší, než baterie v elektrokole.
A v případě, že začne hořet,
tak samozřejmě, že ta teplota je v řádech stovek stupňů vyšší,
než u elektropola.
To nebezpečí obrovské.
Čili nezbývá, než tady tyto autobusy a trolejbusy vyřadit.
Já si moc mluvám čas.
Už?
Čtyři minuty.
Tak já jenom velice stupňu.
Dokončte věc.
Takže pokládám to za velice špatné.
Tyto návrhy jsou teda určitým způsobem
samozřejmě nesmyslné, jsou to ptákoviny.
Ale o co větší ptákovina je,
když tady zakazujete elektrokola.
A jenom velice krátká poznámka na závěr.
Zkuste si u prodejců elektrokol zjistit,
jaká je věkové složení těch, co si je pořizují.
Jsou to ženy vyššího středního věku,
45, 50 plus a 60 plus.
Jenom ještě dokončím,
žádná společnost na světě neostraktizuje
a nešikanuje starší muže a starší ženy.
A já budu doufat,
že Zlín zůstane demokratickým a solidním městem,
který si tyto věci nedovolí.
Děkuji vám za pozornost.
Taky vám děkuji.
Tak, jak jste si zaškrkl v přihlášce,
písemně vám odpovíme do 30 dnů.
Děkuji vám.
Druhým vystupujícím pan Hrůza.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové.
Dobrý den, pane primátore.
Tak jak jsem v minulosti slípil,
tak dodržuji tento slíp
a vyjádřím se ke zvýšení domovních daní.
Je to nemožné, jak okolí to zvedli.
Minulý týden jsem obdržel k zaplacení složenku,
tak jsem se domníval,
že to bude to snížení dělat víc.
Ale je to pořád šestkrát víc,
než před těmi třemi lety.
Což se mně nelíbí
a rozhodně také spoustě druhých lidí.
No, dále bych chtěl upozornit,
že ty náklady, co máte
s tou akcí toho více účelového domu
a jiných, na kterou si berete
značnou půjčku u komerční banky.
Nevím, proč zrovna komerční,
to je francouzská banka.
To, když máte družbu s Francií,
tak neznamená, že musíte mít francouzskou banku.
No, jsou tady spousta bank i českých,
tak ty bychom mohli podporovat.
Nerozumím tému,
třeba mi to někdo vysvětlí.
Není o všem, nejde jenom o peníze,
jde taky o to,
že byste měli být solidární,
protože třeba takové ty české banky
docela dost podporují tady
místní sportovce, hokejisty a podobně.
No, dále bych chtěl upozornit,
že je tady velice dobře vedený
ten magazin z lín.
Opravdu je tam vytýšené hlavně pochvaly
a jsou tam uvedení,
včetně fotografiích.
Tady hlavně lidé,
kteří tady sedí vepředu
a ti drobní, co jsou zastupitelé,
na ty se nedostane.
Ti prostě nemají tu samou propagandu.
No, tak je to 930 tisíc výtisků
a když to má každý v rukou,
tak to má nějakou sílu.
No, tak buďme přímeji v to.
No, dále bych chtěl také upozornit
na to zadlužování.
Tomáš Baťa, jeho kredo a heslo bylo,
buďte věřitele nikoli v dlužnici.
No, ale tady je to vedené obráceně.
Čím víc, ale je to i na jiných místech,
čím víc se zadlužit,
mi je to lepší. No, takový je trend.
Dále pan Baťa skutečně,
to bylo teďka pořád o něm,
tak to vzpomínali
a toto prohlásil.
No, dále bych chtěl upozornit,
že opět začne
po dokončení té přeložky,
té silnice, co vede na Velikovou,
se rozkopávat ulice Zámecká,
protože se tam bude dělat
nová připojka v plínu.
No a tak je to trochu divné.
Já jsem tam zažil už,
co se dělala ta cesta,
se znovu rozkopávala ohledně káblů,
ale to byl krátký úsek.
No, tak teďka to bude holší.
No a tak to je tak dané.
No ale jinak budu už končen,
nebudu tady trčet dál,
nic kam to nevede,
bez tak na nic to nezměním,
takže bych to doklepal do těch voleb nějak
a pak už bych to mám chuť zabalit.
To určitě budou mít spoustu lidí radost,
ale opravdu to nikdo nevede,
protože ty odpovědi jsou takové,
že škoda mluvit.
Jo a děkuji za slyšení.
Děkuji za dodržení časového limitu,
pane Hruza.
Před tím vystupujícím,
pan Šaur,
poprosím z mikrofonu.
Děkuji, máte slovo.
Děkuji.
Vážený pane primátore,
vážené zastupitelky
a vážení zastupitelé.
Navazují na naši petici
a na problematiku rozšíření
parkovacích míst u věžových domů.
Děkuji magistrátu za obsálou odpověď
týkající se bývalé čerpací stanice
u domu čisopopisné 861.
Z odpovědi však vyplývá
několik poměrně závažných skutečností.
Město historicky potvrdilo
existenci čerpací stanice
v daném prostoru.
Zároveň ale uvedlo,
že nemá dokumentaci
o odstranění podzemních nádrží.
Neví,
zdají jsou nádrže stále v zemi.
Nemá statické ani geotechnické posouzení.
Neeviduje ekologickou zátěž
a zároveň nemá plán dalšího řešení.
Jinými slovy,
město dnes vlastně neví,
co se pod tímto územím nachází.
Přesto se celá věc
uzavírá pouze konstatováním,
že lze předpokládat,
že likvidace proběhla správně.
Já se proto chci zeptat
velmi jednoduše a prakticky.
V místě stále existují poklopy
po bývalých podzemních nádržích.
Proč je město neotevře
a neověří skutečný stav?
Nemluvím o žádné drahé investici
ani rozsáhlé sanaci.
Mluvím o základním technickém
ověření reality v terénu.
Protože pokud město nemá dokumentaci,
nemá posudky
a neví,
zda tam nádrže jsou nebo nejsou,
pak přece to není normální,
aby po 40 letech
vycházelo jen z domněnek.
A současně připomínám,
že obyvatele věžových domů
dlouhodobě řeší kritický nedostatek
parkovacích míst.
Byla by škoda předem odmítat
možné řešení parkování
jen proto,
že město nikdy
pořádně neprověřilo
stav území
po bývalé čerpací stanici.
Děkuji za pozornost.
Já dovolím si jednou krátkou reakci.
My jsme samozřejmě začali
prověřovat dokumentaci,
protože je to více jak 40 let,
kdy ta čerpací stanice
byla uzavřena.
Takže jsme začali tím,
že jsme jak na katastru,
tak ve státním archivu naklečůvce
chtěli dohledat dokumentaci k tomu,
jestli ta čerpací stanice byla
odstraněna tak, jak bývalo
v té době zvykem,
to znamená na základě
projektových dokumentací,
případně rozhodnutím
stavebního úřadu v té době.
To se nám prokázat nepodařilo,
to znamená předpokládáme,
že v té zemi ty nádrže jsou.
Dalším krokem samozřejmě
bude odevření těch nádrží.
Předpokládáme,
že jsou zasypány
nějakým inertním materiálem,
protože na těch nádržích
vyrostla zeleň,
v současné době tam
zeleň neustále je
a nikdy jsme tam
žádné problémy,
co se týká ekologické zátěže,
nezaznamenali.
Takže myslím si,
nevím, jestli je přítoven
šef v městské zeleně,
ale je to majetkově spadající
pod městskou zeleň
a plánujeme tam samozřejmě
ty nádrže otevřít
a podívat se, co tam je.
Takže na příštím zastupitelstvu,
případně písemně vám odpovíme,
tak jak žádáte,
jak ten průzkum dopadl.
Jenom průběžná informace.
A děkuji za zdržení
časového rámce
a to byl poslední vystupující.
Víc přihlášek nemám,
pane primátore, předávám slovo.
Děkuji všem vystupujícím
i panu tajemníkovi
za vedení tohoto bodu
a budeme pokračovat dál,
co znamená dalším bodem programu
je schválení dnešního programu
zasedání zastupitelstva města Zlína.
Dne 12. května 2026
byl uvolněn doplněný návrh
programu, do které byl zařazen bod,
kterým je nesouvlast
s vymezením akcelerační oblasti
AOS 5 Malenovice,
který jste spolu s ostatní materiály
obdrželi v elektronické podobě
a v programu je otíslován tak,
jak byl dodatečně zařazen.
Tam se znamená někdo
navržený programu připomínky
či doplňky.
Poprosím pana Skálu.
Vážení zastupitelé,
vážené vedení,
radnice,
řeknu to zkráceně,
nebo v polovině roku 24
jsme schválili bezpatnou dopravu
seniorů od 80 let.
Já jsem si dál tu práci
a prověřil jsem,
jak je to v republice.
Byl jsem z toho velmi zklamený,
tak jsem zajel jenom
na moravské kraje
a na moravské statutární města.
A realita je taková,
vzal jsem za Čech jenom Prahu.
Tam je to od 65 let,
Brno od 70 let,
Ostrava od 65 let,
Olomouc od 65 let.
Průměrný věk dožití
v České republice
u mužů 77 let,
už jen 83 let.
Ta naše hranice je prosrandu.
Většina mužů se prostě
nesveze zadarmo bez líně.
Takže já by navrhoval,
abychom tu hranici snížili
na 72.
Můžu teda se zeptat,
když si navrhujete,
aby se do dnešního,
do dnešního zastupitelstva
přidal bod týkající se
jako z...
A máte takový návrh,
prosím,
jako písemně.
Tak můžeme to udělat tak,
že to nachystáte,
proč taky teda ten bod
a abychom vůbec měli
o čem hlasovat
teda do příštího zastupitelstva.
Protože to,
že tady řeknete ten návrh,
jako tomu rozumíme asi všichni,
víme, co se tím chce říct.
A já bych to otevřel v diskuzi,
že tam víceméně není problém,
abychom to tam prozečili tam.
Ale my v současné chvíli
jako nejsme podle mě schopni
řešit usnesení,
pokud ho nemáme navržené,
nemáme vlastně vůbec podklady
k tomu jednání,
protože co se týká,
abychom o tomto měli
relevantně rozhodnout,
tak si myslím,
že bychom měli mít podklady
o tom, kolik by to město
z ní stálo navíc
a další vlastně,
další aspekty
a vedle toho také předjednanou
tuto,
nebo aspekty otevří
tuto jednání také
s městním Otrkovice,
a neschválí město Otrkovice,
tak to je vlastně k ničemu.
To znamená,
protože na změně tarifu
musí být souhlas
obou zastupitelstv
jako v měst Zlína,
tak Otrokovic,
takže tam je potřeba
opravdu ty věci jednak
předjednávat s Otrokovicemi
a druhá věc je,
že opravdu pokud o to máme
řešit a hlasovat,
tak bychom měli mít
u sebe relevantní informace
o tom, kolik by to reálně stálo,
kdyby to mělo dopad
na rozpočet města Zlína.
A tam se s nás dělali srandu,
že koupujeme na jedné straně
za desítky a stovky milionů
elektrické trolejbusy
a na druhé straně
máme nejvyšší hranici
pro seniory v České republice.
Myslím si, že je to sluda,
že bychom se na tým měli zamyslet.
Jestli to budeme projednávat
na příštím zastupitelstvu,
já jsem to chtěl navrhnout
proto, aby neřekl,
že je to předvolební akce.
No, můžeme si o tom říkat,
jak chceme, každopádně
já za sebe jenom řeknu jednu věc.
Seniori ve Zlíně
nejezdí za tisíce korun ročně.
Ve Zlíně je senior pás,
který stojí, pokud si pamatuju,
správně 600 korun na rok.
To znamená, když to vezmete,
je to 600 korun,
kdybyste to viděl do teda 12,
tak se bavíte,
že to je 50 korun měsíčně.
Já nevím, jestli 50 korun měsíčně
je tak vysoký výdaj,
který by ten senior nemohl dát,
jako já chápu, že je trend
a populistickým způsobem
tady všechno říkat,
že je všechno zadarmo,
ale my na městskou hromadnou dopravu
doplácíme přes 220 milionů korun ročně
a jako začít tvrdit,
že to je zadarmo,
to prostě tak není.
Takže za mě,
jako to, že někdo má zaplatit
50 korun měsíčně za to,
že může jezdit jak chce,
podle mě není jako nějaký vysoký výdaj
a nemyslím si za sebe,
že bychom jako tohle měli nějakým způsobem rušit.
Jako srovnávat město Zín s Prahou,
tak když už se bavíte v Praze,
tak prosím tam zkuste teda dojednat,
stejně jak tam jednám já,
že dostaneme v rámci rozpočtu
učení daní místo 22 067
a pak to doje městskou hromadnou dopravu,
dejme když je pro všechny zdarma.
Ale my srovnáváme jabka s ruškami
a ten důvod, proč ve Zlíně
je vlastně ta hranice od ta,
řekněme takto výšší,
pro ty obročany, kteří mají jezdit zdarma,
je ten důvod, že jsme nechtěli,
aby měli problémy s vyřizováním
právě toho senior pasu,
protože samozřejmě už v tomto věku
jezdit na dopravní podnik
a domlouvat se a vlastně řešit tady
vyřízení toho senior pasu
prostě je pro ně náročné.
Ale ta myšlenka nebyla o tom,
že se nemají žádným způsobem podílet
na, řekněme, na provozu
městské hromadné dopravy,
ale opravdu, abychom odlehčili
ty administrativy.
A prostě ty věci opravdu v něco stojí.
Koro penězí, tam jde o to.
Já jsem si teď dal tu práci,
několikrát jsem tou dopravou jel
v době od 9 do 12 hodin
a ta doprava není úplně vytížená,
takže myslím si, že kdyby tam
těch pár seniorů se svezlo zadarmo,
souvisí to i s tím,
že ti seniori tam držíjou starší auta
na sídlišti, kterýma jedou
třikrát, čtyrikrát za měsíc.
To by mohli udělat klidně
za jedci nakoupit nebo k doktorovi
tím trolejbusem, pokud jelom je zadarmo.
Vy potřebujete prázdný parkovič,
či to souvisí, to není jenom o penězi.
Jak říkám, pokud o tom máme hlasovat,
tak tomu za mě musí být připraveny
relevantní podklady, které k dnešním hodin
nejsou tady na stole.
Takže pokud já nemám problém
se o tom tady bavit, ale prosím,
dejme si na stůle jako relevantní data,
ať vůbec víme, jaký to má případně dopad,
to, že některé spoje nejsou tak vytížené,
tak v tom případě se taky může říct
jako návrh, že teda pojďme zrušit,
jestli teda chceme se bavit o nějaké ekonomice,
což si taky nemyslím, že je úplně správně.
A jako argumentace, že seniori mají
někde zaparkovaná auta, která využívají,
a když budou mít tu městskou hromadu dopravu
o 50 Kč měsíčně levnější,
tak ji začnou využívat i na nákupy,
tak to si myslím, že oba dva víme,
že asi nesmysl.
Takže jakoby prakticky můžeme se o tom bavit,
já s tím nemám vůbec problém,
ale pokud to má být na programu zastupitelstva,
tak prosím dodržujme jednací řád
zastupitelstva města Zdíná
a zároveň pokud je tedy nějaký bod,
který se má přidat,
tak k němu musí být podklady,
aby bylo o něm jak hlasovat.
To znamená, to není v současné chvíli
návrh na změnu usnesení,
to znamená u bodů, který máme v programu
a máme k němu informace,
ale vlastně aktuálně nemáme ty podklady,
co se týká například té ekonomiky
a důpadu na rozpočet.
Takže prosím, já to vůbec neodmítám,
tu debatu, ale prosím,
nejme k tomu relevantní data napřed.
Prosím, že pana Skálu.
Můžu ještě?
Já bydlím na silišti v Malenovicích,
to je siliště, které je postavené zhruba 60 let,
tam těch starších lidí je poměrně hodně
a myslím si, že toto opatření by nemuselo stát tolik peněz,
a že by dopravní podnik třeba na příští zastupitelstvu
mohl udělat nějaký návrh,
kolik podle jeho představ by to stálo.
Určitě jsme schopni zajistit ty informace,
abych se vám to rozesla, to není problém,
ale prakticky proto já vám říkám,
že dneska ty informace nemáme k dnešnímu dní,
tak jenom prosím, pokud se o to máme bavit,
tak mějme i všechny informace, to je za mě celé.
Poprosím, že náměstka Miroslava Chalánka.
Já děkuji za slovo, pane primátore.
Hezké dopoledne, dámy a pánové.
Já jenom krátkou reakci přes ty peníze.
Pan primátor říkal 65 až 80 600 korun celý odpás,
to znamená korunou 80 na den.
V případě, že půjdeme s tou hranicí níž,
tak samozřejmě z tržeb dopravního podniku něco vypadne.
Dá se říct, že zhruba 10 let je nějakých 7 až 8 milionů korun.
Ta otázka je, někdo to bude muset zaplatit.
To znamená, že máte dvě možnosti.
Buď toto vezmete ze salda, to znamená z té investiční rezervy,
o které se tady bavíme, že ji budeme používat,
anebo zvýšíte určité, pokud to chcete vyrovnat vevnitř,
tak v rámci stanovení ceníků to přenesete na určitou skupinu lidí.
Můžete to převést, na děti to nepřeneseme,
takže na tu nejpočetnější skupinu těch pracujících právě,
to jsou ty rodiny s dětmi, které dneska tu hromadnou dopravu
využívají nejvíc.
Samozřejmě jsou tam nejvíc zastoupení jak tržbami,
tak vlastně tou samotným využíváním.
To znamená, že jestli něco navrhujeme,
tak já jsem pro, ať se o tom pobavíme,
je potřeba si říct ty čísla a navrub, čeho to půjde.
Protože to někdo bude muset tomu dopravnímu podniku zaplatit.
A nebo potom musíme říct, že snížíme,
když by tady bylo 8 milionů korun,
tak musíme snížit kilometry o nějaký kilometry,
to znamená, že tu obslužnost toho území začneme omezovat,
což samozřejmě zase pro tu nejpočetnější skupinu
není dobrá zpráva, protože oni ju nejvíc využívají.
Takže dostáváte se prostě do toho systému,
který my považujeme za spravedlý v tom,
že pokud ho někdo využívá v nějaké výši a v nějakém rozsahu,
tak prostě se na něm bude nějakou úrovní podílet.
A úroveň této skupiny obyvatel je koruna 80 za senior pas denně.
Já to ještě doplním o jednu informaci.
V současné době probíhá jednání mezi městem Zlínem a Zlínským krajem
o opravdu plné integraci městského hromadné dopravy
do integrované dopravy Zlínského kraje.
V současné době tato integrace funguje,
prostřednictvím aplikace Fertig.
A na druhou stranu vnímáme samozřejmě ty potřeby
o nějakým způstobem té integraci plnohodnotné.
A v případě, že k ní dojde, že se domluvíme na podmínkách,
tak vlastně přejdeme v rámci tarifu na podmínky
to, co má Zlínský kraj, to znamená 75 let.
Od 75 let je to více mi jako zadarmo.
To znamená, toto je v rámci toho jednání samozřejmě,
že musíme pak sjednotit tady ty ceníky,
včetně té věkové hranice.
Takže tam jenom, ať si to tady řekneme,
že ta jednání probíhají, ale mají spoustu návazností
právě finančních, které prostě řešíme.
A pokud k tomu dojde, podaří se to dojednat,
tak tu danou chvíli je samozřejmě,
stane se samozřejmě také i ta snížení té hranice
věkové procesování zdarma.
Poprosím ještě pana Skálu.
Je to finančně třeba náročné někdo dát čísla na stůl,
ale nemůžete mi vykládat, že v Ostravě jsou jiné podmínky,
v Olomouci jsou jiné podmínky, v Brně jsou jiné podmínky
a z lín je nejhorší.
To je trochu moc.
Já vás poprosím.
Tak znova, říkám to tady už jako dlouhodobě
a myslím si, že nechci se úplně opakovat.
Jediné, co je relevantní na srovnání,
je více méně Olomouc,
ale musíme si říct, kolik má Olomouc obyvatel,
jaké služby nabízí,
nebo když řeknete, že v Olomouci jsou,
můžeme říct si srovnatelné služby,
jako jsou ve Zlíně,
ale výsledku se na ně skládá zhruba 100 tisíc obyvatel,
zatímco ve Zlíně se na ně skládá 75 tisíc obyvatel.
Takže my vlastně jsme o, když to odečtete CEC,
nějaký 20 tisíc obyvatel krát,
i kdyby to bylo krát, 20 tisíc korun,
tak se dostáváte na 400 milionů korun.
A od 400 milionů korun my máme menší rozpočet
a oni mohou mají naopak vyšší
a můžou z tohoto platit různé tyto služby.
Co se týká, prosím, Prahy, Plzeň, Brna, Ostravy,
nesrovnávěme se s nimi,
protože tam ta hra je úplně jiná,
protože Plzeň, Brna, Ostrava dostává na občana
z rozpočtučení daní 37 tisíc korun.
Takže to je, jestli my dostáváme 22 tisíc,
tak oni dostávají na každého občana
zhruba o 15 tisíc navíc.
Takže to srovnání je, prosím, nás úplně mimo mísu
a přestaňme tohle, prosím, dělat.
A naopak napněme všichni své síly, kontakty
a všechny možnosti, které máme,
aby se konečně rozpočtučení daní změnilo,
protože jinak si tady budeme přesně tyto debaty
neustále vést a dívat se,
proč to v těch čtyřech zvýhodněných městech jde
a v ostatních to nejde.
To je prostě pořádat, co můžeme bavit,
jak chceme, vždycky je to o penězích.
Vždycky na těch penězích skončíme.
Poprosím ještě pana Chalánka.
Pak se doplním pana primátora.
Pane Skálo, je to takhle.
Řeknu to na placato.
Kdyby z lín měl 90 tisíc obyvatel,
tak co se týče vozového parku a nákladů,
spojené vlastně s provozem té dopravní společnosti,
by se nemuselo stát vůbec nic.
Možná by nám ty náklady zrostly o 2 %.
Ale prostě my chceme ve městě,
které má 70 tisíc obyvatel
a kde máte jakýsi limity z lískaté přepravy,
vybudovat síť městské dopravy,
která obslouží to území a ten počet obyvatel.
A samozřejmě já taky jezdím trolejbusem.
A taky jezdíme, nejede ten trolejbus úplně plnej,
tam by se vešlo daleko víc lidí.
Ale prostě ten poměr toho přepravovaných lidí
a té dopravy, nebo nákladu té dopravy,
prostě máme ten poměr těch 70 tisíc lidí
vůči tomu dopravnímu podniku,
není úplně ideální.
A tudíž kulhá to srovnání, o kterém vy říkáte,
kolik je to, co si může dovolit Olomou,
za co si můžeme dovolit my.
Pan Kocháň víc lidí než 70 tisíc z hlediska té přepravy
mít nebude.
A vozový park máme postavený možná na 80,
že bychom byli teď schopni přepravovat,
aniž bychom museli cokoliv z hlediska
vlastně nákladu té společnosti udělat.
To je ta výkonová spotřeba, prostě tam nějakým způsobem pro nás
není výhodná, ale prostě s tím nic neuděláme.
Tudíž to, co říkáte, a má to jakousi logiku,
já tomu rozumím, jako srovnání,
tak jako srovnáváme něco, co úplně srovnávat nelze.
A vyvozovat z toho záběry, proč oni a proč ne my,
bohužel ty podmínky jsou jiné.
Dobrá, já jenom poprosím, vzhledem tomu,
že jsme v bodu návrh programu dnešního jednání,
já teda poprosím, vrátíme se zpátky do toho,
jakým způsobem hovoří jednací řád zastupitelstva města Zlína
a já v tuto chvíli beru, že tu je návrh pana Skály
na zařazení bodu snížení limitu pro snížení věkové hranice
pro městskou hromadnou dopravu ve Zlíně
pro občany, kteří by jezdili zdarma
a dám prosím hlasovat o tom,
jestli tento bod chceme zařadit na program dnešního jednání.
Takže prosím pojďme hlasovat o tom,
jestli tento bod, který návrh pan Skála,
bude zařazen na program dnešního jednání zastupitelstva.
Pro deset, takže tento bod na jednání zastupitelstva dneska nebude
a prosím, když tak dořežeme si ten zbytek ještě v diskuzi klidně,
ať to můžeme otevřít.
Každopádně, myslím si, že ty informace k tomu dneska zazněly.
Poprosím ještě pana Skálu.
Děkuji těm, kteří to podpořili,
protože si uvědomili, že jednou budou taky staří
a že budou rádi, když budou mět možnost
kdykoliv nasednout na trolejvu,
zazající k doptorovi a nedržet kvůli tému auto.
Nicméně jsou rád, že se tím budeme aspoň zabývat,
takže třeba dozrajeme k tomu, aby jsme to udělali.
Já jenom doplním možná informací jednu
a už pojďme, prosím, půjdeme dál.
Senior v současné době existuje ve zimě senior taxi,
takže není pravdou, že si musí držet auto,
aby dojel na nákup anebo k panu doktorovi.
Potřeba si říct, že ta služba tady také existuje.
Takže jenom prosím, neříkejme tady věci,
které jsou určitými domněnkami
a není to prostě úplně asi relevantní k tomu vodu.
Poprosím ještě ráměstka Mirka Chalánka s technickou.
Je jenom krátkou technickou na pana Skálu.
Já teda počítám taky s tím,
že jednou budu starý, akorát,
a že budu využívat, že si ten senior pas koupím
a že na to finančně budu připravený.
Počítám taky s tím, že se stavnu.
Dobrá, děkuji. Poprosím ještě pana Kocháně.
Prosím vás, pane Skála,
zlejný k tomu, že čísla, o kterých vy mluvíte,
mě hodně zajímají, tak vím,
že z hlediska ročního růstu senior pasů
jsme ve srovnání meziročním nahoře.
To znamená, ti naši občané využívají to městskou dopravu
a pochopili, co je to senior pas v těch cenách,
které tam dáváme.
Dobrá, prosím vás, máme, máte někdo něco dalšího,
co se týká programu dnešního jednání,
kromě bodů, který byl navržen a nebyl schválen
na zařazení dnešního jednání,
který případně prosím probereme dále v diskuzi?
Pane Skála.
Já jenom chci říct, že to beru,
že to neprošlo ten návrh, je to demokratický,
ale myslím si stejně, že by o tom se mělo přemýšlet,
protože kdybyste žili na tém sydlišti,
tak vidíte, jak to tam běží
a ono, ten život je trochu jinak,
jak ho vidíme tady mý.
Děkuji za pozornost.
Dobrá, děkujem a já teda poprosím náměstek Michala Čížek.
Já vás zdravím, já si neodpustím to komentovat
a doufám, že to uzavřu.
Pane Skála, to nebylo, že se o tom nechceme bavit,
jenom jako to je mimořádný bod na zastupitelstvo.
Proč jako dneska?
Když to tady funguje x let,
tak se pojďte potkat, pojďme si o tom pohovořit
a dejme to jako normální bod třeba na zastupitelstvo.
A jestli si to nezavnímal,
tak pan privantová říkám,
že s krajem vyjednáváme integraci
a dojde k automatickému snížení té hranice,
nemusíme dělat vůbec nic.
Jestli to chcete ještě níž,
pojďme se o tom bavit,
ale ne na mimořádný bod zastupitelstva.
Nechme si předlužit nějaké data,
pojďme se o tom bavit jako betekla.
Čili dneska jsme zamítli,
aby to bylo mimořádný bod zastupitelstva,
ne, že se o tom nebudeme bavit.
Děkuji.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Má nějaký další návrh
na úpravu dnešního programu zastupitelstva?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže prosím, pojďme hlosovat
o návrhu programu 26. zaseň
zastupitelstva města Zdína,
tak jak jste ho dostali
v rámci aktualizace dne 12. května.
Pro 36. program 26. zaseň
zastupitelstva města Zdína byl schválen.
Násled je bod číslo 4,
kterým jsou rozpoštová opatření.
Poprosím náměstka Mirka Chalánka
o komentování tohoto bodu.
Já děkuji za slovo, pane primátore.
Já, pokud budou dotazy,
samozřejmě odpovím,
ale já bych vás poprosil
o doplnění tabulce číslo 6,
řádek 3,
kde se jedná o transakci
týkající se stezi,
protože my tam vlastně
pro letošní rok snížujeme,
snižujeme tu dotaci
na úhradu pro kazatelné ztráty.
Jestli si vzpomínáte,
je to částka do 100 milionů korun,
takovou pro letošní rok.
V tuto chvíli snižujeme
o 3 miliony 684 tisíce korun.
A já bych vás tam poprosil
vlastně v této části
o doplnění,
že se jedná o smlouvu,
protože z toho textu
údajně z hlíska
našeho právního oddělení
nám chybí číslo té smlouvy,
aby jsme to měli úplně perfektní.
A ta smlouva je číslo
20.0026.004
ze dne 5.1.
Jinak ta transakce je taková,
že my to v letošním roce snižujeme
a vlastně
prostřednictví dohadných položek
navýšujeme ten rozpočet
smlouvy toho plnění
z loňského roku
pro rok 25.
Je to z důvodu toho,
že v rámci vlastně
účetní uzávěrky
posouzení vlastně
všech těch věcí,
které se během toho roku 25
se staly,
to znamená,
že tam během roku 25
jsme dávali další objekty
a ty měly samozřejmě
nějaké náležitosti
z hlíska náklady,
z hlíska toho provozu,
údržby a zprávy,
tak vlastně ten
loňský rok
navýšujeme
prostřednictvím
dohadných položek
od tu samou částku,
takže v rámci rozpočtu
je to neutrál,
v tom letošním roce
na úhradu vlastně
ještě toho,
nebo posílení toho rozpočtu
jako za rok 25.
Dobré, děkuji za to doplnění
a otvírám diskuzi
k tomuto bodu číslo 4.
Do diskuze se nikdo?
Poprosím Kateřinu Francovou.
Dobré, dopoledne všem.
Já tady mám jenom
takový jeden dotaz,
takový možná
trošku prakticky.
Máme tady zase,
schvalujeme příspěvek
Městskému divadlu
z dýny na úhradu
na pronájem zábran.
Mně ta částka připadá
docela velká.
Říkám si,
jak dlouho tam ty zábrany
ještě plánujeme.
Jestli by nebylo dobré
už si je koupit,
protože by mě zajímalo,
kolik jsme za to vynaložili,
kolik nás to ještě bude stát,
jestli bychom třeba
neušetřili trošku tím,
že bychom to třeba
nemovitostí by si to pořídili.
Já se přiznám,
že nevětšíme to řešili
na platforme zastupitelstva
nebo v rámci
jenom zastupitelských plubů.
Každopádně jsme to řešili
už v lonském roce
nebo jsme to prověřovali
a vlastně vycházelo nám z toho,
že kdybychom to koupili,
tak nás to stojí mnohem víc
než v současné době.
Každopádně je potřeba říci,
že podoběhla soutěž
na opravu fasády,
kdy v současné době
se kontrolují nabídky
a předpokladáme,
že v radě 25. května
bude materiál
o rozhodnutí výběru dodavatele
a nechci teďka predikovat,
že ještě nemá,
ještě neprobylá komise,
to znamená každopádně
posunuli jsme se k tomu,
že by se divadlo mělo
konečně dostat,
jako dočkat opravy
a tím pádem tady,
říkáme to lešení,
už nebudeme muset řešit.
Můžu?
Jo, pardon.
Do 36.
To znovu na uviníme,
jak říká pan primátor,
teďka máme vysoktěžené,
takže předáme staveniště
a potom už by ten náklad
jako za náma nešel.
Zbratiku, poprosím ještě
Kateřil Francovou.
Já jsem měla jenom ještě
jeden dotaz.
Tady je 6,5 milionů
na vybudování hřiště
na Přílukách.
Určitě ano, je to super.
A chci se zeptat,
kde to hřiště je?
Jenom to je stávající,
které se bude?
To je hřiště na Příluku,
které, když vlastně máte
to fotbalové hřiště,
tak naproti tomu,
když se stavil nový přivaděč
s odstavným parkovištěm,
tak původně v tom projektu
byla ještě i plochá
vlastně na tady toto hřiště.
K tomuto hřiště,
kterého výstavbě nedošlo,
protože jsme se nedohožili
trošku spory z právě
s fotbalovým klubem
zkaze pozemky.
toho prostě už se to nestihlo
dát vůbec do projektu,
protože jsme se taky
nebyli schopni dohodnout,
jaký tam má být povrch a podobně,
protože jsme se snažili
být jakoby stříc
s fotbalovému klubu
a zároveň jsme říkali,
že to má sloužit
celému Příluku,
nikoliv pouze fotbalovému klubu.
V současné době můžeme říct,
že jsme se s fotbalovým klubem
dohodli na tom,
jaký tam má být povrch,
a tím pádem doděláváme
tuto investici
a bude to vlastně
v těsném sousedství
toho stavného parkoviště
naproti já se jít
v fotbalovému klubu.
Další se hlásí
pan Tomáš Dudák.
Dobré dopoledne,
dámy a panové,
pane primátore,
děkuji za slovo.
Já vám prosím dvě otázky.
Jedna návazná
na paní kolegyní.
Jestli v tuto chvíli
je známá nějaká nová částka
celkové investice
nebo nákladu na opravu divadla,
a pak bych si dělal
ještě jednu otázku k bodu.
My jsme vypsali soutěž
na opravu fasády divadla
ve čtyřech variantách
s tím, že ty varianty byly
vždycky to bylo jedna AB
a varianta dvě AB
s tím, že ten Ačko, Bčko
bylo rozlišení o tom,
jestli dělají renovaci kamene
anebo do se dodává nový.
To znamená,
chtěli jsme to maximálně otevřít,
protože jsme měli informace,
že někteří dodavatelé tvrdí,
že levnější je ta renovace
a někteří, že levnější
bude dodávka nového kamene.
Tím, že varianta jedna
byla oprava pouze západní fasády,
posvětlo hlavního vstupu
se vstupem
a vlastně ale ty boční stěny
by zůstaly.
Druhá varianta byla,
že se opravuje kompletně
celá fasáda,
jako všech stěn,
toho divadla včetně výměny oken.
A cena byla zastropována
v té soutěži na 81 milionů
bez DPH,
což byla částka,
o které jsme se bavili
už i na předchozím zastupitelstvu.
A můžu říct si,
že jedna nabídka
na celkovou rekonstrukci,
na celkovou výměnu všetně
všetně výměných oken
se vešla do tohoto stropu.
To znamená,
pokud bude v pořádku,
tak předpokládám,
že rada města z dína
schválí tuto nabídku,
abychom to divadlo opravili
celé, včetně výměny oken.
To znamená,
my jsme schválně zastropovali,
abychom se nedostali
do té situace,
že budeme mít
třeba nabídku
na celkovou opravu,
která je vyšší
než ceny,
které jsme původně
tady již nějakým způzem
předschvádali.
A jsme rádi,
že alespoň nabídka
se do této ceny vešla
a teď jenom uvidíme,
jestli opravdu splní
v rámci kontroly
všechny náležitosti,
které má,
a pokud ano,
tak se pokládám,
že se půjde touto cestou.
Děkuji,
čili to je oprava pláště.
Bavíme se stále
o této investici
jako oprava pláště budovy?
Je to oprava vlastně,
dá se jít oprava pláště,
jak říkáte,
to znamená
vrátšanský vápenes,
to znamená to obložení
celého divadla
ze všech stran
vrátšanským vápencem,
tak tomu se bude měnit,
včetně všech oken
na všech stranách,
včetně kamení,
které je vlastně
v rámci vstupu
do divadla,
to znamená,
když se řeknu schody,
dá se nechci říct,
podláha divadla,
ale to, co je před tím divadlem,
před ten přístup,
bude také vlastně opraven,
to znamená,
dá se říct,
že bude kompletně
celé divadlo,
co se týká těch pohledových stěn,
pohledového přístupu
a oken,
které vlastně už mají
také své roky
a prostě jsme to případně udělat
celé dohromady,
aby se nestalo to,
že se udělá fasáda
a za pět let se budou muset
měnit okna,
a tím se ta fasáda
zase zpátky,
já si řekl by,
ne, že poškodí,
ale prostě nějakým způsobem
se naruší,
takže vzali jsme to
v rámce soutěže dohromady
a můžu říct si,
že prostě jedna nabídka
se vešla do toho
finančního stropu,
který tam byl záměrně dán,
protože vzhledem tomu,
co se děje
s městským rozpočtem,
vzhledem tomu,
co se děje
na stavebním trhu,
tak častěji
to otevřeně soutěží
vlastně aplikujeme
do těch soutěží
teďka stropové ceny,
to zná tu cenu maximální,
tak jak je u teďka
soutěží na velké kino,
tak je vlastně
byla u skateparku,
stejně tak teďka
byla aplikována
na tu fasádu
toho městského divadla.
Abychom se drželi
těch rozpočtů,
které vlastně
nějakým způsobem
se bavíme,
že vychází
z těch předpokládaných tlen.
A pan Duda,
chceš nějaký další dotaz?
Ano, mojí dotaz je prosím
k tabulka číslo pět
přidělení finančních prostředků,
rekonstrukce, kuchyně,
základní školy
Dřevnická.
My se nechceme nějak
jako vyjadřovat
k tomu, jestli je investice
správně nebo špatně,
nezpochybnujeme to.
Doufám, že je ta investice
třeba již také zastropována.
I tenhle mechanismus
se nám samozřejmě strašně líbí
po těch minulých zkušenostech,
kdy se nám to nepovedlo
na spouště jiných akcí.
Tak to velmi kvitují.
Nicméně, k této konkrétní
investiční akci má otázka je,
jestli se nepohybujeme
v nějakém automatickém režimu,
kdy se postupně
rekonstruují školní jídelny
za desítky milionů,
jestli existuje nějaká koncepce
nebo zpracovala se nějaká analýza,
jestli tento model
těch lokálních kuchyní
v rámci těch škol
je dlouhodobě finančně provozně
a personálně udržitelný.
Ta diskuze vím, že tady byla tak
dva roky zpátky, když jsme řešili
jinou jídelnu, jestli nějaká
centrální kuchyně není řešení,
pohnula se rada
nějak v tomto názoru
nebo zůstáváme
v automatickém režimu
a nemyslím to prerativně.
Já pak poprosím
paní náměstkyni,
a tak ažopádně ten stav je ten,
že my v současné době
vlastně, že to řekl,
na území města Zíne dá se říci,
že my určité centralizované kuchyně máme,
celé otevřeně,
což je právě například
jídla na Hradská
a je to například
právě tady tady jídla
té dřevnické.
A ty ostatní,
které jsou, když to řeknu lokální,
které zabezpečují opravdu
pouze tu základní školu,
tak by měly být
relativně v dobrém stavu
nebo dostat nějakou rekonsultu
relativně nedávno.
To znamená, my pak následně
budeme řešit opravdu,
tak jak říkáte,
tak jak jsme se,
už to bylo otevřené,
jestli jsme schopni to
centrálně zabezpečit
a nebo jestli je lepší
jít cestou splnit normy
pro převoz toho jídla,
které taky nejsou zrovna,
až to řeknu,
mírné.
A já poprosím teda
o upřesnění
paní náměstkyni.
Paní náměstkyni.
Děkuji, panu primátore,
za mě také dobré dopoledne,
dámy a pánové.
My v současné době
řešíme tady tuhletu jídelnu
pečlivě, to zvažujeme
u materských školek,
jdeme již jinou cestou,
tam budeme rekonstruovat
pouze jednu už jídelnu
a pokud si dostaneme
do situace,
že ty jídelny tam nebudou
už v komfortu
nebo lepřečeno ty kuchyně,
tak tam už se budeme snažit
to řešit nějakým dovozem,
nicméně samozřejmě
materská školka je
úplně o jiném počtu
než základní školy.
Pro porovnání v těch materských školkách
máme třeba od 40 do 150 dětí
a v těch základních školách
se pohybujeme dneska od 350
a třeba co se týče 4. a 5. základní školy,
tam máme počet tisíc dětí.
Takže zatím nám to ekonomicky ukazuje
pouze tento směr,
samozřejmě některé ty jídelny
nám plní i úlohu
v integrovaném záchranném systému,
pokud se něco stane,
tak de facto se tam vaří
i pro tyto složky,
takže zatím nám to ukazuje
tímto směrem.
Dobrá, děkuji za to doplnění.
Pan Dudák,
jenom, jestli to chcete,
jestli stačí, tak to super.
A poprosím, pane Uráše,
tady se další hlásí do diskuze.
Dobrý den, děkuji, pane primátore.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové.
Já jenom se ještě vrátím
k tomu divadlu.
Poprosím, jestli jsem to správně pochopil,
že vy jste, pane primátore,
mluvil o variantách oprava výměna
a porozuměl jsem správně,
že to zastropování
celkových nákladů
se vztahuje na všechny ty varianty?
Ano, my jsme dali strop
81 milionů bez DPH.
s tím, že vlastně byly možnost
přihlásit se do jedné
nebo do všech variant,
záleží na tom zhotoviteli,
o co měl zájem.
Někteří využili toho,
že se přihlásili tuším do všech,
někteří do tří,
někteří jen do jednoho.
a my jsme měli předpokládanou cenu,
předpokládaná cena na varianty 1A,
což byla využití současného kamene
s tím, že se prostě vyčistí
a ty, které kusy byly špatné,
tak se vymění.
To znamená ta renovace
a jenom ten západ,
jako ta západní stěna,
tak naše předpokládaná cena
byla zhruba kolem 35 milionů,
čemuž se přiblížila jedna nabídka.
Další nabídka byla
jako zase mnohem dražší,
takže kam ještě neprobyla komise,
takže já se přiznám,
že ani nevím,
co všechno ještě můžu prezentovat,
tak to veřejně.
Ta druhá verze byla,
ta jedna B byla vlastně
s tím, že se ten kamene mění všude,
to znamená,
to bylo mnohem dražší
než ta varianta jedna A
a ve variantě dvě A,
to znamená ta kompletní výměna
jako by všeho,
tak se vlastně vešly do toho stropu 81.
Ve variantě dvě B,
která byla s výměnou,
tak tam se do toho stropu
nevešla žádná nabídka,
ale byly podány,
ačkoliv ten strop byl daný,
tím pádem ty nabídky
prostě v rámci toho procesu
samozřejmě na ně budeme
pak jako reagovat.
My jsme to schválně,
jenom abychom to upřesně,
my jsme to schválně udělali takto,
protože jsme,
naším cílem se otevřeně bylo
mít ideálně nabídku
na tu kompletní opravu
a potom samozřejmě,
tím, že jsme nějaké předpokladné ceny
na ty nižší,
tak tam jsme řešili,
jestli tam dáme i ty nižší stropy,
jestli tam to tak nějak musím limitovat.
Na druhou stranu jsme říkali,
že určitě chceme,
aby to divadlo se zbavilo toho lešení,
takže následně proto jsme řekli,
že dáme jenom ten horní limit,
u těch říkáme celkově jeden limit,
nikoliv u těch nižších,
protože samozřejmě,
kdyby nedošla nějaká nabídka,
která by splněla limit
a na celkovou rekonstrukci,
tak předpokládám,
že bychom určitě přistoupili
k té nabídce,
která to řeší,
alespoň tu západní stěnu,
i kdyby byla dražší
než předpokladaná cena.
Předpokládám za sebe.
Bylo by to pak na rozhodnutí
Sary Rady města Zdína,
ale myslím si,
že to divadlo je velké téma
pro nás, pro všechny
a určitě všichni bychom si přáli,
aby tam to rašení nebylo,
takže si moc nedokážu představit,
že bychom vlastně dali stropy všude
a pak třeba neměli vlastně žádnou nabídku
a museli to soutěžit celé znova.
No prosím, náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Jeno v rychlosti takového krátkoho reakce
na pana dodáka.
Určitě, co se týče školství,
pro nás je teďka v tuto chvíli
strašně důležitý,
aby jsme udrželi školství
na tom celkovém budžetu,
který my inkasujeme v rámci daní.
To znamená, my pro letošní rok
máme nějakých 320 milionů.
10 milionů nám tam přibylo
vlastně tarifama.
To znamená, že s paní náměstkyní
prostě ta věc, o které vy jste mluvil,
to znamená optimalizace
a vytvořit ty synergie,
jakou budeme muset do budoucna dělat,
pokud chceme udržet vlastně
ten rozpočet na tom budžetu
z jískatovou příjmu.
A ten je někde na úrovni
pro příští rok 330 milionů.
Čili to je každodenní práce
na tom, jak efektivně ty věci
posluzovat, vyhodnocovat
z hlíska nároku,
nebo z hlíska těch osobních nákladů,
tak, aby jsme prostě udrželi
ten budžet pro školství
v těch intenzích příjmu.
Dobrá, děkuji za to doplnění.
K diskuze si kdo další nehlásí,
takže prosím pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 4.
Pro 27, materiál číslo 4 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 5 je změna
zakladatelské listiny společnosti
nemovitosti města Zlína.
Co se týká nemovitosti města Zlína
a té zakladatelské listiny,
tak my to řešíme už více než rok,
protože nemovitosti města Zlína
samozřejmě jsou městskou společností
a zřešili jsme tam vlastně
problematiku případné veřejné podpory
a dalších věcí.
Na základě všech toho těch vyhodnocení
vlastně musíme tu zakladatelskou listinu změnit
a proto ji máte dneska předloženou v té podobě,
kterou máte,
kdy, abychom se vypořádali se všemi těmi,
řeknu se s veškou legislativou
a ta společnost mohla dál
do budoucna fungovat a plnit to,
proč byla založena.
Jsou k tomu nějaké další dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuse nehlásí,
tak tady jeden střed zájmu,
to znamená Tomáš Krajček má střed zájmu,
prosím, že je jednatovém této společnosti
a prosím, pojďme tady hlasovat.
Pro 32, materiál číslo 5 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 6 se týká opět nemovitostí města Zína,
kdy řešíme schvální ručitelského závazku,
protože společnost nemovitostí města Zína
v současné době dokončuje
položkový rozpočet
na rekonstrukci objektu
kulturního centra v Malenovicích,
známe jako kino Květen,
s tím, že by tato společnost měla vyhlásit
s nejší pravěpodobností výběrové řízení
na tuto rekonstrukci
v červnu tohoto roku
a aby tomu tak mohla učinit,
tak vlastně potřebuje
srde to profinancovat
tuto rekonstrukci
a proto schválujeme
schvální ručitelského závazku
pro tuto městskou společnost.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Poprosím náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Tak poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo.
Dneska tady lítají miliony,
když sečteme dřevnickou divadlo
a tady tu investici,
tak máme vlastně roční rozpočet
na investice i zvyčerpaný,
ten volný.
Naše otázka k tomuto bodu
je z dvou pohledů.
Je to finanční konstrukci
a provozního modelu.
Moje otázka z pohledu těch
finančních věcí nebo konstrukce
jsou asi tři podotázky.
Prvé víte, že my jsme
mířní kritici
ručitelských závazků
nebo jakéhokoliv
braní si úvěru
na naše městské organizace,
protože jistým způsobem
se to stává pro nás
s méně přehledným.
Nicméně má otázka
v tomto smyslu je,
jestli to děláte z důvodu
obav o překročení
dluhové brzdy
nebo je tam nějaký jiný význam.
K té částce
my se zavazujeme
k ručení
na jistinu 100 milionů,
včetně příslušenství.
Možná je fér říct,
že to příslušenství
jsou úroky
při pětiprocentní úrokové míře.
To může být 50 milionů
do roku 48
na těch 20 let,
kdy to chceme splácat.
Takže my tady
v touto operaci
nebavíme o 100 milionách,
ale o 150.
Financování.
Vy v bodu uvádíte,
že město bude posílat
5 milionů ročně
do roku 35,
ale těch 5 milionů,
jestli jenom na úhradu jistiny,
tak tam nevidíme,
jakým způsobem
bude financován úrok
a k provoznímu modelu
tam nevidíme
vlastně vůbec,
kdo objekt
bude provozovat,
jaká bude
úroční náklady,
jaké příjmy,
jak se očekává,
že bude případně
pokrytá
provozní ztráta,
jakože doufám,
že nebude.
Omlouvám si,
že těch otázek je hodně,
ale je to velká investice.
Děkuji.
Já jenom v kostce,
určitě pustím náměstka
Mirka Chalánka,
že mi odpoví
na většinu otázek,
mohl by otvět na všechny,
já jenom v kostce,
jenom ať ten provozní modelu.
Aktuálně to máme
namyšlené tak,
že tento objekt
spadne do
pod,
jakoby,
správu,
co se týká toho
podle provozu
pod kongresové centrum.
To znamená,
využijeme zase,
ještě řeknu,
ty zkušenosti
toho personálu,
který v současné
zabezpečuje
provoz
kongresového centra.
a pak
samozřejmě
řešíme
model takový,
aby bylo možné
odpočítat DPH,
to znamená,
bude tam
standardní pronájmy
a samozřejmě
nějakým způsobem
ještě řešíme cestu,
aby to bylo
možné
plně odpočítat
DPH,
protože bez toho
to je pro nás
jasná priorita
a zároveň,
aby to bylo
samozřejmě
střícnější
pro některé spolky,
to znamená
pro ty spolky,
která komise
v Malenovicích
nějakým způsobem
oslovila,
že by tam
prostě měly být
pravidelně
a tam se nabízí
stejný model,
jako je
mezi
nějaká
rámcová smlouva
mezi
tak, jak máme
s Filharmonií,
že má
trošku
zlepšené podmínky
proti
standardnímu ceníku,
protože je to
dlouhodobý nájemce,
takže
touto cestou
dost možná
se půjde
pro
s určitým subjektem
v rámci
prostě těch Malenovic,
aby ty spolky,
některé tam
prostě byly za
nižší cenu
než je ceník,
protože tam mají být
jakoby pravidelně
nebo z těch dlouhodobě
a tak dále.
To znamená,
je to jedna z těch
variantenů,
co řešíme,
aby to sloužilo
opravdu tomu,
to jí ta komisa
nějakým způsobem
si přeje.
A poprosím teda
náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Děkuji za slovo.
Tak já to vezmu postupně,
když bych na něco zapomněl,
tak mě,
pane dodáku,
připomeňte.
Ručitelský závazek
bereme
jako na sebe.
Ten důvod,
proč
není vůbec důvod
dluhová brzda,
to určitě ne.
My máme pořád
ještě rezervu
na to,
kam došáhneme
a je to ještě tak,
jenom abych vysvětlil,
dluhová brzda
je stanovená
na 60%
příjmu
průměrného příjmu
za poslední čtyři roky.
Dluhové závazky.
Potom jste povinen
platit 5%
to, co převyšuje.
To znamená,
že v momentě,
kdy úvěr berete
na 20 let,
tak tu podmínku splňujete
a nemusí vás to úplně
limitovat v tom,
jestli můžu
nebo nemůžu.
ale důležité je,
abych na to měl.
Čili tam nejsme
v tom,
jako že by jsme nemohli,
ale spíš,
že si na to máme.
My samozřejmě
potom to berete
z toho salda,
to znamená,
že město je
vybaveno
na to,
aby ten závazek
na sebe vzalo,
čili to je ten důvod,
proč ručíme
nemovitostem.
To je první věc.
Druhá věc je,
nemovitosti si berou
ten úvěr,
protože kino je
v jejich majetku,
takže ono vlastně
si to bere
na svůj majetek.
Z lístka hospodaření
nemovitosti je to tak,
že nemovitosti mají
zhruba majetek
za půl miliardy
a ten pronajímají
vlastně městu.
To znamená,
že ten obchodní vztah
je tvořený
vlastně městem
a společností nemovitosti.
To znamená,
že my jsme to měli
nějak nastavené tak,
aby jsme byli schopni
splácat jenom tu zprávu,
ale časem jsme se dostali
trošku jako do problému
v tom,
že neměli jsme
to úplně,
řekl bych z hlíska,
zákony
dobře nastavené.
To znamená,
že byť jsou nemovitosti
stoprocentně vlastněny
městem,
tak samozřejmě
musí respektovat
nějaké nakládání
s majetkem.
To znamená,
že jsme se dostali
do kategorie transferových cen
a tam jsme museli
vlastně
odvodit
z toho pravidla,
jak stanovení,
jak se stanovují
transferové ceny
nějaké
nájemné,
které
inkasují
nemovitosti
za majetek,
který pronajímají
statutárnímu městu.
Čili není to tak,
ale nějak to uděláme,
ale prostě to má
nějaká pravidla.
To znamená,
že ten nájem
my navýšíme
v letošním roce
a myslím si,
že je to tady
v materiálu,
tak ho budeme
muset navýšit.
Pro letošní rok
je to 4,5 milionů korun,
který budeme
navýšovat.
To znamená,
že to bude výnos
na straně nemovitostí,
kterým budou kryt
případné
to příslušenství
spojené
s tým úvěrem.
Až to celé
se zrekonstruuje
a to kino
vlastně se udělá,
tak se samozřejmě
nabede do majetku,
zbydou na nemovitostech
naskočit 2 miliony odpisů,
čili ty budeme muset
a protože ty transferové ceny
se počítají
z odpisů,
počítají se z nákladovosti
a tak dále,
tak my počítáme,
že město
bude muset nemovitostem,
ale bez ohledu na to,
na co ty nemovitosti
to použijí,
budou muset platit
zhruba nějakých
9 milionů korun
za nájem těho majetku,
čili tam se dostáváme
do pozice toho,
že budeme mít kryté
to příslušenství
a to bude navrub
samozřejmě
statutárního města,
čili vytváříme zdroje
na to,
aby jsme kryli to příslušenství.
Co se týče té jistiny,
to je jiný příběh
a dohoda byla taková,
protože na nás tlačilo
i komise místních částí
v Malenovicích
a vlastně ten požadavek
v těch Malenovicích
byl s kýnem květem
něco udělat
a my s panem Krajíčkem,
když jsme tam jezdili,
tak a s panem Robenkem,
tam jsme se domluvili
s komisí,
že na dobu deseti let,
počínaje rokem 26,
se zdají části svého příspěvku,
který dneska máme
zakomponovaný
už v rozpočtu,
to jsou ty,
to je těch 25 milionů,
které dáváme
komise místních částí,
z toho 8 milionů
je příjemce
komise místních částí
v Malenovicích
a 5 milionů
bude na 10 let
vlastně
my nebudeme přidělovat
s komisím místních částí,
ale bude to zdroj
na úhradu jistiny,
to znamená,
že jistinu budeme krít
z příspěvku
komise
a až to nastane,
protože v letošním roce
jsme třeba tímto příspěvkem
vykryli projektovou dokumentací,
která byla zhruba
své výši 4,5 milionů,
potom tím kryjeme
náklady spojené
vlastně s tím bunkovýštěm,
které vytváříme
pro poštu
a tak dále.
Takže počínají
příštím rokem,
nám tam samozřejmě
bude
naskočit
ty transferové ceny
a to nájemné
v roce
po navedení majetku
po rekonstrukci
kina květen,
tak tam budou
2 miliony odpisů
a jediné,
co potřebujeme vyřešit,
protože i když to spočítáte,
tak ještě ty výnosy
z hlíska toho pronájmu
a náklady na jistinu
nedosahují té výše,
tak to budeme kryjít
vlastně každý rok
podle toho,
jak toho hospodaření
bude vypadat,
tak to budeme kryjít
vlastně v případku
mimo základní kapitál.
Takže my to vždycky
dokryjeme
do té výše,
která bude potřeba
zhlískat
těch aktuálních výnostů
té společnosti
v daném roce.
Chceme to dělat tak,
aby zhlískat transparentnosti,
že vždycky
ke konci roku
spočítáme tu nákladovost
těch nemovitostí
a těch výnosů,
čili budeme mít
předběžný
hospodářský výsledek,
kterého můžeme
dosáhnout v roce následující.
Ta stabilita těch cen
bude poměrně velká,
protože tam budete mít
jednu jedinou
nájemní smlouvu,
která bude mezi
nemovitostí a městem,
takže tam se dá říct,
že ta stabilizace
toho výpočtu
zase nebude tak složitá
a podle toho,
kolik tam těch peněz
bude chybět,
tak bude příplatek
mimo základní kapitál,
který budeme
už rozpočtem
na ten příští rok
vždycky
pro ty nemovitosti
fixovat.
To znamená,
že budeme každý rok
v rámci přípravy
rozpočtu už vědět,
kolik by ten příplatek byl.
Takže to je takovej
konstrukt vlastně,
jak jsme,
jak dneska
zamýšlíme
s kynem.
Ještě jedna podstatná věc,
která to nezazněla,
podmínka toho všeho
je zase stejně tak,
jak jsme to dělali
u velkého kyná.
Musíme udělat odpočet,
to znamená,
veškeré fungování
kynakvěten
bude udělána tak,
aby jsme zajistili
odpočet DPA.
Dobrá, děkuji.
a poprosím,
další se hlásí
pan Cáha.
Já se domnívám,
že je to příliš komplikované
a nemyslím si,
že by jsme měli
dát
ročitelský závazek
za tady tuto aktivitu.
To chce lepší logistiku
k tomu vymyslet jednodušší,
tak, aby to bylo
srozumitelné
a na konci bylo
malé plus.
Takže
za mě
jako
není to připravené dobře.
Oblouvám se.
Já jenom můžu říct si,
že jsme se opravdu
snažili to udělat
co nejjednodušej,
ale samozřejmě
potýkáte se tím,
že vlastně
majetek je
opravdu ve vlastnictví
soukromé společnosti
a podobně.
To znamená,
a snažili jsme se opravdu
to udělat tak,
aby to bylo
co
nejvcísnější
vůči rozpočtu města
z dína.
Takže, abych to řekl.
Takže samozřejmě
proto ten konstrukl
může vypadat
složitější.
Na druhou stranu
je nastaven tak,
aby byl předvídatelný
co se týká
i toho rozpočtu,
takže,
nebo respektive
při stvorbě rozpočtu
a podobně.
Takže to je to,
proč vám to tady
pan náměstek
tak to jakoby
dopodrobná vysvětloval,
ale ono pak ty mechanizmy
v rámci toho
nebudou zase tak
jakoby složité.
Jenom
co na to vypadá,
ale
prosím ještě
pana Sáhu.
No já by v tom případě
to, co tu bylo řečeno,
kdyby se položilo
ještě ve více
zjednodušené formě
na papír,
tak aby
k tomu každý
si mohl udělat
představu,
jakým způsobem
ty mechanizmy budou
a pořád si myslím,
že
tady ty dlouhodobé
závazky
bez
jasné představy,
jak to budeme
všechno řešit,
protože je tam
ještě
několik velkých otazníků,
jak jsem pochopil
a vůbec ta
ekonomická stabilita
v současném době
je taky docela
dobrý otazník,
takže opatrnost
při dávání
závazků
je na místě.
Takže já
v podstatě
asi to
nebudu,
buď se
asi se zdržím
tady v tomto případě.
Jasné, rozumím,
to my se snažíme
být co nejopatrnější,
ale
musíme taky
ty věci udělat,
takže musíme
hledat, hledáme cesty
a toto vlastně byl
výsledek opadu
od delší doby
řešení, jak to nastavit.
Poprosím ještě
na městka Mirka Chalánka,
chtějte reagovat.
Když to na první
dobrou slyšíte,
tak se vám to
základá komplikovaný,
ale v zásadě to
respektuje
ten
systém
nebo ten
stav, který
dneska jako máme.
pokud máme obavy
z toho,
jak to bude,
nebo jestli na to máme,
tak já bych řekl,
že fakticky tím,
že
využíváme
vlastně peníze,
které jsou dneska
už v rozpočtu rozdělené
a my akorát děláme
vnitřní přerozdělení,
protože my je bereme
jako my jsme jistních částí
a dáváme je
na
uhradu
jistiny
nebo počítáme s ní,
že s ní budeme
kryt jistinu,
tak
otázka je,
jako kdyby jsme,
jaké riziko postupujeme.
Postupujeme na 10 let
a nevíme,
asi nikdo z nás,
co bude za 10 let,
tak postupujeme riziko takové,
že za 10 let,
ano,
bude muset
statutární město
z lín z línka
svýho rozpočtu
vytvořit opravdu
těch 5 milionů
anebo 7 milionů
výzkum myslím jistních částí,
že bude dál pokračovat
s té spolufinancování
té věci.
Nám tady
vedlejší náklad
vzniká jenom v tom,
co říkal pan Dudák
a to je v tom příslušenství,
což samozřejmě
v čase se bude snižovat.
Protože budete splácat jistinu.
Nevím, jak bude vypadat
úroková míra,
jinak ty podmínky
toho úroku
jsou za stejných podmínek,
jako jsme brali úvěr
na ITI,
to znamená,
jako plovoucí sazba,
třiměsíčný přibor
a nárok
na předčasné splnění
bez podmínek.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Další slavství,
pan Juráš.
Děkuji, pane primátore,
za slovo.
Já jenom drobně
k té diskuzi.
Dvě poznámky,
jeden dotaz.
První,
ručitelský závazek.
Tak, děkujeme
panu náměstkovi
za to vysvětlení.
Nutno ale poznamenat,
že ručitelské závazky
se napřímo neprojeví
v rozvaze,
ale v podrozvahové položce
a nevstupují do výdajů
schváleného rozpočtu.
Jinými slovy,
při ukazatelích
dluhové služby
to není sledovaný moment,
proto byl ten dotaz
na tu dluhovou brzdu
a jakoby se tváříme,
že ten závazek nemáme
a on obživne až ve chvíli,
kdyby byl potřeba plnit
a v té chvíli pak se musí řešit
mimořádnými rozpočtovými opatřeními,
aby se zaplatil.
První poznámka, druhá.
To, o čem se bavíme s vámi,
je, že bychom rádi věděli
ten takzvaně provozní model
toho kulturního centra.
Nás nezajímají odpočty DPH,
což je určitě důležitý faktor,
ale pokud říkáme,
že si myslíme,
že je důležité to udělat,
tak by bylo fajn
buď otevřeně říct,
že pořizujeme do vlastnictví
města majetek,
na jehož údržbu a zprávu
budeme muset vynakládat peníze,
protože pokud nám nepřinese
měřitelný užitek,
tak nám přinese jenom
měřitelnou ztrátu.
Nic dalšího tam nebude.
A důležité je si vedle sebe
položit to,
jestli ten takzvaně neměřitelný
užitek, jak vy říkáte,
setkávání občanů,
kulturní centrum,
vyvažuje tu takzvaně
měřitelnou ztrátu.
Protože já to budu udržovat
a zpravovat do té doby,
dokud ten majetek nedožije.
A poslední ještě poznámka,
pak přijde ten dotaz.
My rozumíme tomu
splácení z hlediska úroku,
ale to příslušenství
v té maximální míře
při nezměnitelnosti
úrokové sazby,
to je taky korektní říct,
může jít nahoru,
k tomu rozumíme,
je nyní 150 milionů.
A dotaz, který k tomu máme,
jak bude řešeno,
pokud by ta investice
měla překročit 100 milionů.
Bude taky zastropována,
nebo jak k tomu budeme přistupovat?
Tak já to rovnou předám
na pana Krajíčka,
který vlastně k tomu opravdu
ty věci řeší,
takže já to předám jemu
a případně, co ne,
ještě by bylo potřeba doplnit,
tak doplníme.
Jenom myslím, že ty otázky
než se opakují,
ale myslím, že potřeba to rozvést dát,
tak jak chcete,
tak určitě předám s tvojou
panu Krajíčkovi.
Dobrý den všem.
Já jsem se teda snažil přihlásit
jako poslední,
abych zodpověděl dotazy,
které ještě zodpovězené nebyly.
Možná na začátek bych poděkoval
za prvé panu náměstkovi Chalánkovi,
jeho ekonomickému odboru,
taky právníkům,
protože ono se to nezdá,
ale v podstatě transformace
společnosti nemovitostí
a příprava tohoto projektu
v podstatě probíhá už rok,
rok intenzivně.
A jenom když se vrátím
ještě trošku do historie,
ať máte představu,
tak objekt bývalého kina Květen
v Malenovicích,
který stále teda slouží
jako aktivní kryt civilní obrany,
funguje tam Česká pošta,
městská policie,
je potřeba si říct,
tak byl zavřen vlastně provoz
toho, té kulturní části
v roce 2013
a v roce 2022
měl být rekonstruován.
Měl být rekonstruován
z dotací,
na které jsme bohužel nedosáhli,
stavební povolení tam máme
a v podstatě čekalo se,
jestli se za ty dva, tři, čtyři roky
prostě najde nějaký vodnější
dotační titul,
který by se na to dal aplikovat.
Z hledem k tomu,
že nic takového se neobjevilo,
ani se nepředpokládá,
že by se objevit mělo,
tak vlastně došlo k tomu,
že jsme i, jak říkal pan Chalánek,
byl enormní zájem
místní části Malénovic,
přece jenom je to největší
místní část, kterou máme
a krom Sokolovny tam v podstatě
nemají objekt nebo prostor,
kde by se mohli setkávat,
tak došlo k té dohodě,
že vlastně se budou podílet
na té rekonstrukci.
Co se týče provozního modelu,
v tuto chvíli se provozní model řeší,
jak už bylo řečeno,
tento týden byla schůzka
s panem Jordánem,
kde jsme právě řešili
a nastavovali,
jakým způsobem by se to provozovat mohlo,
co to bude stát.
V tuto chvíli to má spočítat,
má to dát na papír.
Představa je taková
a ta představa vlastně vznikla
a přišla od,
nebo z požadavku té místní části
že to chtějí využívat
hlavně a převážně oni.
Mám seznám deseti,
možná dvaceti spolků,
jsou to základní školy,
materské školy,
jsou to spolky na tančení,
na divadla, na zpívání,
jsou tam i včelaři, harmonikáři,
v podstatě průřez všemi spolky,
kteří mají zájem
v podstatě na týdenní bázi,
každý týden pravidelně,
ten sál využívat.
A ano, samozřejmě nabízí se,
taky po zkušenostech od pana Jordána,
se nabízí využívat,
a v podstatě ta spádovost
může být od napajedel
po zase tečovice místní části,
vlastně okolo,
využívat ten prostor také komerčně,
ať už na nějaké oslavy,
případně plesy a tak dále.
Takže ten provozní model v tuto chvíli se tvoří,
ano, bude nastavený tak,
aby vlastně dokázal pokryt náklady
provozu nebo chodu toho objektu.
Možná nutno ještě teda podotknout,
ten objekt tam stojí
a v tuto chvíli díky tomu,
že se temperuje,
tak ono to taky úplně není zadarmo.
Takže on, i když je zavřený,
tak v podstatě ho stále platíme.
a co se týče dluhových brzd,
tak to potom bych poprosil,
jestli jsou k tomu ještě nějaké dotazy,
asi na pana Chlánka.
A zodpověděl jsem vše
nebo je potřeba ještě něco doplnit?
No, já si myslím,
že tam asi bylo postupně všechno.
Kdyby ne, tak se prosím doptejte
a další hlásí ještě pan Simkovič.
Pěkné odpoledne,
nebo ještě dopoledne všem,
pomlouvám se.
Já bych ocenil,
že byla snaha rady města
nějakým způsobem s ním pohnout
a najít cestu, najít řešení.
Žádné řešení asi není úplně ideální.
Nám se to jeví s příměřenou mírou
rizika jako řešení,
které posouvá ty manovice a tu výstavbu.
Takže si to dovolíme podpořit.
Ale ten provozní model
asi bychom velmi rádi.
Tak to je, že viděli.
A když vybudujeme ten majetek
a jak říká pan Krajíček,
když se tam přestěhou z další spolky
někdy by mělo být nějaké úspoře.
Takže rozumíme tomu,
že asi to nebude výdělečné.
Tyhle věci nebudou nikdy výděleče.
Na druhou stranu,
to město má nějakou službu.
Nám to připadá,
že by tohle mělo dávat smysl.
Je to tak,
že ten provozní model,
tak jak tady bylo řečeno,
musíte, že ta komise
si udělala nějakou poptávku
s nemovitostí města Zína
se i na základě zkušeností
pana Jordána
si taky vlastně vyřešila
nějakou potenciální poptávku
a na základě toho
se bude ještě podrobněji zjišťovat
opravdu ta reálná poptávka,
která ještě řeknou podobu.
Za dva roky se to s rekonstruorem
může být jiná než jiný,
ale je to vlastně ten důvod,
aby se zjistilo,
jakým způsobem nastavit
opravdu například i tu cenotvorbu,
protože tak, jak bylo řečeno,
abychom mohli odpočítat DPH,
tak samozřejmě ten objekt
musí být pro něj má za komersní ceny.
Takže samozřejmě cílem
a cílem pro nás je,
aby ten model
a ve výsledku nemáte
ani jinou možnost,
pokud chcete odpočítat DPH,
že ten objekt vlastně nemůže být v mínusu.
Takže na základě toho
budou nastavené i ty ceny
a na základě toho
seřejmě se budeme bavit,
jakým způsobem
vlastně tam bude
v nějakých vůzovkách rozvrh,
protože musíme na základě
těch počtu hodin,
které budou poptává na těmitových spolků,
ať už týdně, měsíčně
nebo jakým způsobem
k tomu nějaký prostor volný
pro tady ty plně komersní akce,
které slyštěku na ty nepravidelné,
tak vlastně v tu danou chvíli
z toho se vlastně bilancuje
a řeší se opravdu ten ceník,
který dnešnímu dni
bude jiný,
než to, jaký bude
ke dní za dva roky při otevření.
Takže my teďka spíš řeším
opravdu spíš tu poptávku
a podle toho se to nastavuje
a následně i ta samotná cena realizace,
když samozřejmě
každá stava má nějaké více práce,
méně práce a podobně,
tak prostě se budeme snažit řešit,
aby ten provozní model
prostě vycházel alespoň v nule,
tož abychom také splněli
ty podmínky pro odpočet DPH.
Poprosím pana Dudáka.
My bychom rádi navázali
na pana Simkoviča
to, co jsme ji říkali.
Opravdu bychom zdvořili
požádali.
Pan Krajíček to má nějak vymýšlené.
Kdyby to šlo v průběhu tří měsíců
hodit na papír,
poslat nám to,
ať si dovedeme představit,
jak vlastně,
jaký ten objekt generuje
náklady plánované
v současných cenách.
Proti tomu,
jaké budou výnosy,
nemusí to být nic světoborného,
ale ať máme jenom
jakousi hrubou představu
o tom,
o jakých nákladech
se tam bavíme,
protože to je pro nás
úplně v mlze
a v tomto materiál
není žádný podklad
k tomuto hodnocení.
A na pana Chalánka
děkuji.
Ten materiál je fakt
z pohledu manažerského
jako finančního řízení
opravdu dobře promyšlen.
Děkuji za tu práci
celému řadu,
kterou jste na tom odvedli.
Otázka, která nebyla
zodpovězena,
co když ty náklady
nebo vysoutěžená nabídka
bude větší
než 100 milionů korun.
A jestli tam také
uvažujete,
že to bude
podobné modelu
jak to divadlo
anebo
se budeme tady bavit
za nějaký měsíc
o nějakém překvapení.
My jsme tady řešili,
celéž jsem se právě
otáčil na
pana Krajíčka,
jestli se bude stropovat,
protože my vlastně
opravdu reálně
a teďka ji pan Chalánek
vedle říká
budeme stropovat.
Je to prostě
teda ta cesta,
kterou my vlastně
opravdu řešíme,
předpokládám za sebe,
že bude vyzastropovaná cena
v rámci soutěže,
abychom zase prostě
vzhledem k tomu,
že máme nějaké
rozpočtové ceny,
máme předschválený úvěr
v nějaké výši,
tak prostě,
abychom nedopadli,
že budeme mít
tu cenu v stavbě
úplně jinou.
To znamená,
z největší právě
první první,
tam půjdeme do toho
potenciálního rizika
se zastropovanou cenou
s tím, že
budeme muset
tu soutěž
například opakovat,
a kdyby se nikdo
nepřihlásil
do té zastropované ceny
a ten provozní model
určitě není za mě
problém z těho
dát na papír,
protože to je to,
co se aktuálně řeší
a my vlastně
obecně se na tom
vlastně pracuje
ve spolupráci
s panem Jordánem,
takže určitě ty věci
dáme dokupy
aspoň rámcově,
jak to vlastně
kdo vnímá
a v tu danou chvíli
vám to dáme také
a jak jsem řekl,
prostě tím cílem
je plný odpočet DPH,
a to znamená,
on to prostě musí být
provozně schopné
být nesmít,
aby to nebylo v mínusu.
Poprosím ještě
náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Pane primátore,
jenom krátko reakce
na pana Juráše.
Ano, máte pravdu,
jako samozřejmě
nebude to v podrovlaze,
počítáme s tím.
Já jsem ani to nezlehčoval,
tu zadluženost.
Já jenom chci říct,
že teď to není úplně...
Ten rozpočet totiž
má jednu věc,
jakože pokud
v rámci toho porovnávání
započítáváte i dotace,
on vám vytváří
obrovskou možnost,
jako z hlediska
té dluhové služby
nebo té brzdy,
která vůbec není relevantní
k tomu saldu
a schopnosti splácat.
Takže to je to takové,
proto já mluvím o tom,
aby jsme měli
tu možnost
nebo respektive
vytvořit ty podmínky
pro to,
aby jsme byli schopni
vlastně ty závazky hradit.
A jinak,
jenom v tom provozním modelu,
my jsme samozřejmě
v tomto začátku
a jsme uvažovali tak,
aby v tom
základě bylo
popsané vlastně,
od čeho se má
ta úvahu odvíjet,
to znamená,
chceme odpočítávat.
To znamená,
že ono vám to pořád
bude definovat vlastně,
jakým způsobem,
s kým můžete,
protože v těch dlouhodobých
závazích
musíte jít s plácem DPH,
takhle jako jo.
Takže to je jenom jako proto,
když to budeme zpracovat,
aby jsme měli rámec,
jako v kterým se budeme pohybovat,
protože při investicii
100 milionů
bavíme se
o celkem velký peněz.
Takže
pro tuto chvíli jsme
si ten rámec učili.
Dobrá, děkuju.
Poprosím pana Juráše.
Já se omlouvám,
nedá mi to.
Dám takový příměr,
že bych raději
obrátil ten postup
a dám to na příměru rodiny,
která si pořizuje auto.
Auto je v našem případě
kulturní centrum.
Tak mám za to,
že rodina pořizující si auto
se nejprve nepořídí auto
a pak hledá jeho možné využití
nebo jaké náklady
ho to bude stát.
Když si pořizuje auto,
řekne si, kolik mám členů rodiny,
jaký mám rozpočet
a k čemu je to vozidlo
má sloužit
a podle něho vybírám
v té cenové relaci.
Když ho budu chtít
nikoliv pro služby členům rodiny,
aby je převážili z místo na místo
nebo aby převážilo nějaký náklad,
to znamená neměřitelný užitek,
tak v tom případě
budu hledat ten měřitelný.
Když budu chtít podnikat,
tak zvolím jiný typ auta.
Počítám, kolik převezu zákazníků
nebo nákladu
a jaký to bude mít výnos
a podle toho si řeknu,
na co mám
a co si můžu dovolit.
Já mám trochu pocit,
že tady jsme to obrátili.
To je ta celá výtka.
Ne, není tomu tak úplně.
Můžu se bránit, co to bude.
Ne, prakticky je to čistě o tom,
že samozřejmě ve spolupráci
s toho komisí,
která vlastně zase ve spolupráci s námi
a dalšími dělá vůbec tu poptávku,
tak se upravoval i ten projekt
toho celého Kina Květen
k tomu, aby tam mohlo být
co největší využitelnost
právě na základě té poptávky.
To znamená, samozřejmě se zjišťovalo,
uspůsobovalo se, aby to bylo opravdu
co nejširší škálu.
Já řeknu zcela otevře,
že k mému překvapení je tam zájem,
základíško, že tam bude dělat
hodiny tělocviku.
To prostě pro mě je nepředstavitelné,
proč tady to má být.
Ale prostě snažili jsme se fakt
víc říct v rámci toho projektu všem,
proto vlastně došlo k úpravě toho projektu
proti tomu původnímu,
který byl nachystaný před takřka čtyřmi lety
na konci toho minulého volebního období,
kdy se řešilo, že bychom mohli získat dotaci,
kterou jsme nakonec nezískali
a na území města Zdína
ji získal Zdinský kraj
a vlastně díky tomu vznikla
zrekonstruovanáči Perová vila.
Tak tento projekt se z tohoto projektu
se opravdu došel ke změnám,
jak tak, abychom ho,
když to řeknu, nech si prolevnili,
ale ve výsledku, abychom tam nemuseli mít
ty věci, které tam musely být k tomu,
aby se splněly ty podmínky
tehdejšího dotačního titulu
a vedle toho zároveň,
aby se opravdu naplnila co nejvíce
ta poptávka, která v té lokalitě je.
Takže ten projekt samozřejmě
je nastavený tak, aby tu poptávku
co nejvíc, co nejširší škále
prostě byl schopný pojmout
a to, co nemáme, to, co řešíte,
že jsme vám nepředložili,
ale reálně to nemáme,
je prostě nějaká cenotvorba
nějakým způsobem, kolik ta hodina
bude stát a tak dál,
protože v současné době
vnímáme náklady, řešíme
prostě opravdu
ten model, protože
jsou rozdílné představy
a neříkám zásadně,
ale jsou do určité míry rozdílné představy
mezi námi
a mezi například komisí
a kdy prostě se,
teď to řeknu, například komise
by byla nejradši, kdyby od toho měla klíče
a celým způsobem si tam pustila,
koho potřebuje a tak dále,
řešila to ta komise
nebo zástupce té komise,
což samozřejmě zase z pozice naší
není možné, protože potřebujeme
pod ním nějakým způsobem přehled
a řešit nějaký rezervační systém
a podobně, takže to je to,
co my v současné době nemáme
ještě vydefinováno přesně s tou komisí,
protože musíme
tady ty pravidla
nastavit a zadržovat, abychom ji taky byli
schopí kontrolovat ten příjem, aby bylo jasně
stanovené, komu se platí za jakých podmínek,
takže to je jedna věc,
kterou musíme si usadit právě
jakoby z komisí
místní části Malenovice,
nevnímáme tam nějaký zásadní rozpor,
ale samozřejmě je to ta věc,
která se promítá
do provozních nákladů, protože samozřejmě
pokud to bude dělat, teď to řeknu někdo
na dobrovolné bázi, no tak toho člověka
platit nemusíme, pokud bude z té
místní části a pokud to bude placený člověk
plnohodnotně,
který bude jenom pro potřeby
tohoto objektu, no tak samozřejmě zase bude
stát nějaké peníze ročně
a v tu danou chvíli to musíme promítnout do těch
provozních nákladů. Takže
to je to, proč tady ten provoz dneska nemáte,
protože potřebujeme usadit
ještě tady tyto věci, co se týká
opravdu toho provozu
s komisí a na základě
toho se doladí opravdu
ten provozní model tak,
abych byl, řekněme, to nejrelevantnější
už na začátku.
A prosím, náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Pane primátor,
já jenom krátkou reakci na pana
Juraše, na to přirovnání. Já bych to řekl
tak, jako, pokud
si pořizuju nové auto a do té
doby jsem chodil pěšký,
tak je to velká neznáma.
My přecházíme ze škody
ze škody
na FAB
a nějakou zkušenosti máme.
Máme 15 let
zkušenost s provozováním
kongresového centra, kde ten začátek byl
taky o tom, kolik to bude stát atd.
A kongresové centrum dneska
funguje a dokonce
dobře není schopnost
zaplatit odpisy, ale
zprovozně je ziskové, jo.
Takže my tyto, řekl bych,
zkušenosti samozřejmě chceme přenést
i do těch, do té FABě, jo.
A myslím si, že tak s úplně neznámou
nepracujeme, i když v tuto chvíli
samozřejmě nejsme schopni úplně
detailně popsat, co tam bude, jak to bude atd.
Protože do toho vstupuje ta komise místních částí.
Vždycky, když se něco novýho objeví, tak bude spousta nápadů,
co kdo by tam mohl dělat, ale já si myslím jako,
že to zadání je takové, aby prostě to provozně
vůči rozpočtu nebylo nárokové, jo.
Takže to je jenom bez stručnosti.
Dobrá, morská děkuji za to upřesnění.
Nikdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže já prosím pojďme vlastnout o materiál číslo 6,
tím, že i v tomto materiálu je střed zájmu pana Krajíčka.
Pro 30, materiál číslo 6 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 7 týkající se sloučení materských škol.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Do diskuze se nikdo nehlásí, takže prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 7.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 7 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 8 týkající se schválnění financování projektu
pro společné zachování a rozvoj vlaťovského odkazu.
S tím, že já prosím, doplňte si do tohoto materiálu
číslo usnesení rady města Zdína, které je 81 lomeno 8R lomeno 226.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí.
Prosím pana Juráše.
Já jenom čistě, aby jsme byli koherentní v přístupu,
tak tady nám taky chybí to, jak uvažujeme o budoucím provozu
toho rekonstruovaného domku, na který čerpáme tu dotel,
na který čerpáme ty finanční prostředky a nevidíme tam.
Prvozní model máme a já věřím tomu, že odbor kultury a památkové péče
společně s odborem majetku, kteří jsou velcí zastánci tohoto projektu,
ho ještě vyšperkují a pak ho k něm předají dál, abyste věděli, jak to mají v plánu.
Poprosím, jsou jestli nějaké další dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 8.
Pro 31 materiál číslo 8 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 9 je opět jeden z dotačních projektů,
tentokrát z lín a trenčních dialogů, takzvaný kulturní a kreativní most 226.
A poprosím vás opět, jestli si doplníte do materiálu číslo usnesení rady,
které je 37 lomeno 8 R lomeno 2026.
A otvírám diskuzi k tomuto bodu číslo 9, prosím, jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 9.
Pro 36 materiál číslo 9 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 10 je implementace integrovaného území strategie z línské aglomerace.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Níkdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 10.
Pro 27 materiál číslo 10 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 11 týkající se územků.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Poprosím Kateřinu Francovou.
Tě jednou dobré dopoledne.
Já se mluvám, já rychle roluju.
Tabulka číslo 10.
Jsou tady nějaké nesouhlasy s odboru s tím, že by se nejprve měl vyřešit vztah k pozemku pod přístavbou v rámci nějakého řízení o povolení a potom teprve schvalovat.
Tak nevím, jak to úplně, jestli jsem tomu dobře porozuměla.
Jestli mi to někdo může vysvětlit.
Já vím, že to je jenom nějakých pár metrů, ale jestli by nechtělo prvně desítka.
Já poprosím paní vedoucí, paní Husákovou, jestli by to mohla upřesnit.
Tam jde o to, že zase tou digitalizací se zjistilo, že něco stojí na městském pozemku, takže se to doladilo.
Je to dlouhodobá stavba, legální.
Dobrá, moc káme děkujeme za to upřesnění.
Poprosím, jestli jsou nějaké další dotazy k materiálu číslu 11.
Nikdo se v rysku zde hlásí.
Poprosím ještě pana Rudáka.
Děkuji za slovo.
My máme jenom informaci, že některé body nešly přes majetkovou komisii, které tady vidíme.
Jenom, jaký je v tom vlastně mechanismus, kdy to jde a kdy to nejde přes majetkovou komisii?
Poprosím ještě paní vedoucí, ať vám.
V tomhle případě nešly přes majetkovou komisii takové drobné transakce,
které se týkají akce modernizace, elektrizace, tratí od rokovice z lín,
protože ty smlouvy přišly na poslední chvilku, tak jsme hned, jak to bylo možné,
to předložili do rady, aby se stihlo dnešní zastupitelstvo a dále se nedošlo k prodlení
a majetková komise to dostala na vědomí.
Dostala to ve středu v den, kdy se odesílali materiály na zastupitelstvo.
Dobrá, tady u těchto bodů se jedná o nemalé peníze a zároveň o nemalou stavbu,
tak vlastně se přikročilo k tomu, že je hodnější vůči subjektů,
který se k tým zavíjámem tuto smlouvu, to vlastně projít v co nejkratším časovém termínu,
abychom, řekněme, nespomalovali a nespomalovali ty procesy, které tam aktuálně k tomu mají.
Jsou vlastně k materiál číslo 11 nějaké další dotazy?
Jestli tomu tak není, prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 11.
Pro 26, materiál číslo 11 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 12 týkající se pozemků, kdy řešíme výkupy pod komunikací,
způsobám se, jestli jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 12.
Pro 33, materiál číslo 12 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 13 se týká pozemků, tentokrát o bezúplatnému převodu
v katastranném území Zlín a v katastru v katastranném území Štípa.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 13.
Pro 33, materiál číslo 13 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 14 týkající se také pozemků, tentokrát je to směná smlouva
ze hřiště z TSO Malenovice, jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 14.
Pro 34, materiál číslo 14 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 15 týkající se nabítí majetku, nepatrné hodnoty.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 15.
Pro 34, materiál číslo 15 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 16 týkající se neinvestiční dotace z rozpočtu na provoz veřejných koupaliští v roce 2026.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 16.
Pro 34, materiál číslo 16 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 17 týkající se investiční dotace z rozpočtu města Zdína na technické zhodnocení sportoviští
ve zprávě městské společnosti Sceza Zlín.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 17.
Pro 33, materiál číslo 17 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 18 týkající se názvu ulic v katastrálním území Hlouky na Dřevnicí.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se v diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 18.
Pro 35, materiál číslo 18 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 19 týkající se návrhu počtu členů zastupitelstva pro budoucí volební období,
226 až 30, kdy návrh je, aby zůstal stejný počet, jako je nyní,
to znamená 41, to znamená počet, který platí od roku 2006.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 19.
Pro 35, materiál číslo 19 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 20, změna ve jmenovité složení komise,
novětových komisí, jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže já vás poprosím,
napřed budeme hlasovat o tom, že budeme hlasovat aklamací,
materiál číslo 20, takže pojďme prosím hlasovat o způsobu hlasování aklamací.
Pro 35, tak a teďka pojďme prosím hlasovat materiál číslo 20,
k tomu aklamací.
Pro 30, materiál číslo 20 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 21, týkající se nesouhlasu s vymezením
akcelační oblasti AO S5 Malenovice.
Já jenom bych chtěl poděkovat vlastně aktivitě pana Robenka
a všem vlastně, kteří se klem této problematiky točí,
to znamená námestek Vojta Volv s životním prostředím
a ostatními, kdy samozřejmě vnímáme,
že bývalá vláda začala řešit akcelační oblasti
skrze dotační titulu z Evropské unie,
kdy se bavíme zhruba o jedné miliardě eur
a vlastně s tím, že nastavila
nebo vybrala na zákadě nějakých dokumentů
akcelační zóny.
Současná vláda ten návrh z těchto oblastí zmenšila
a to víc snad více než o 90%,
to znamená nějaká desetina toho, co tady původně bylo navrženo
a v současné chvíli je samozřejmě otázkou,
jak ty parametry nebo jak to vlastně bylo nastaveno,
protože vnímáme, že ta lokalita v Malenovicích
úplně nedává smysl pro solární elektrárnu,
která je převážně na severním svahu.
Zároveň podle nás nesplňuje odstup od bytové zóny
a jsou tam další aspekty, kdy tu lokalitu
využívají občané Malenovic pro trávení volného času
a prostě moc to tam nedává logiku
a vnímáme také nějaké nestoulady právě v těch dokumentacích,
které odůvodňují, proč ta lokalita byla vybrána
a například průzkum živočíchů a podobně.
To znamená, tyto všechny věci si vyhodnocuje
odbor životního prostředí ve spolupráci
také vlastně podporu s panem Robenkem,
který je v intenzivním kontaktu také s ministerstvem pro místní rozvoj
a abychom měli naše, aby naše zdůvodnění
nesouhlasů bylo co nejsilnější,
protože za nás prostě vnímáme,
že v této lokalitě si nemyslíme,
že to je opravdu správně,
ale zároveň už je velice složité
jakákoliv debata o přípodném přemístění,
takže hledáme všechny možnosti
a uděláme všechno pro to,
abychom byli úspěšní,
protože opravdu tato lokalita je
hojně využívá na občany Malenovic
pro trávení volného času
a opravdu pokud tyto věci,
pokud ta zelená energetika má vznikat,
tak proti tomu asi nikdo není,
ale je to potřeba na těch lokalitách,
kde to prostě není,
a teď to řeknu,
naprosto rušivým elementem
pro občany
jednotlivých měst a občí.
Chce bych se zeptat,
jestli teda někdo má k tomuto nějaké dotazy
v rámci tohoto bodu?
Poprosím paní Špalkovou.
Dobrý den, neúplně dotazy,
ale chtěla bych říct,
že plně respektujeme a podporujeme
názor občanů Malenovic
být proti záměru
k navržené akcelerační oblasti
v Malenovicích na Svárovci
a to jak na úrovni zastupitelů
SPD města Zlína,
tak aktivně na úrovni zastupitelů
Zlínského kraje.
Děkuji.
Dobrá, děkuji. Poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo.
Já se bojím teď cokoliv říct,
aby to nevyznělo politicky
i špatně před volbama.
Ale žádné takové vystoupení
nebo proklamaci připravenou nemáme.
Jenom bych
bez ohledu na tuto lokalitu,
já se k tomu nevyjadřuji,
kde to je a proč to je,
jak to vzniklo akcelerační zóny,
jaký byl záměr
a co je toho výsledkem,
jak to je blbě odkomunikováno.
A jenom prosím, aby jsme
tak, jak se
v tomto kolektivu snažíme
celkem zodpovědně zacházet
s městským rozpočtem.
A já děkuji, že tady není žádný řvoun,
který řekne,
dejme na tyto, na tyto a tamty
a nehleďme, kolik nás to bude stát.
Tak bychom naprosto korektně
jako s dlouhodobém horizontu
měli vést i diskuzi
a chápu, že tady toto je jako první level
jenom veřejného mínění.
Že prostě bez té oze energetiky
se prostě neobejdem.
A jestliže si budeme říkat,
jak strašné a hnusné a škodlivé
jsou ty větrníky,
tak ať mi pak někdo vysvětlí,
jak vypadají stožáry v krajině.
Viděli jste někdo do uhelný důl,
jak vypadá, jak ta krajina
celá kolem je poškozená.
A ty doly a ty stožáry v krajině
jsou tu k tomu,
aby jsme měli energii,
aby jsme za ní platili,
zaplať pán Bůh tolik, co platíme,
když je to strašně moc
v porovnání s tím, co bylo.
Ale prostě pokud
tu zelenou energetiku
nevyřešíme do budoucna,
tak budeme platit podstatně víc,
než platíme dnes,
pokud ta energetika bude.
To, kudy se posouvá v tuto chvíli
česká energetika,
je k tomu, že se spolehá na importy.
A ty importy budou převážně z Německa,
jejíž zelená energetika
je už někde dneska na průměru
daleko vyšším,
než v České republice.
A bez větrníků
nevyřešíme elektriku
přes zimní období.
Ne, určitě vám naprosto rozumím
a to je proč já jsem končil
to mé vystoupení
nebo ten úvolk tomu materiálu
tím, že my nejsme
z pozice Rady města Zlína
jako proti, řekněme,
té zelené energetice.
Stejně tak se nechceme chovat
jako, když to řeknu ve stylu,
nemáme s tím problém,
ale hoďme to k sousedovi
nebo někam jinám.
To znamená, tak jak to známe
častokrát z nějakých
stavebních řízení,
nemám s ničím problém,
ale ať to není vedle mě.
My pouze říkáme,
že my jsme nebyli vlastně
přizváni vůbec
v té debatě
o tom výběru těch lokalit.
My respektujeme plně,
že ty lokality někde musí být,
protože tu máme závazek
vůči Evropské unii
a v hodnotě miliardy eur
a vlastně ta miliarda eur
už se částečně začala i čerpat.
Takže to není o tom,
že by se vláda rozhodla
a více mě se jenom škrtne to,
že to k nám nedoteče.
Ono už se to začalo čerpat.
Takže my se snažíme
být konstruktivní
a opravdu spíš jenom řešit to,
že tato lokalita
prostě není vhodně zvolená
z vícero důvodů,
kdy jedním z nich je samozřejmě
opravdu ta těsná blízkost
k těm občanům.
A ty lokality jsou,
ještě jako i v blízkosti,
řekněte, to lokality jsou
lokality, kde by další,
kde by to mohlo být postaveno
a nebylo by to nějakým způsobem závadné.
Protože samozřejmě například
i dálnice D55
prostě pokračuje
a prostě má vedle sebe
nějaké lokality,
čtyří polí,
ale prostě různých míst,
kde by se to dalo umístit
například i ve větším rozsahu.
A nebylo by to tak dráždivé
vůči těm občanům
toho, řekněme, našeho města,
případně okolních měst.
Takže to je spíš ten problém,
který my vnímáme,
kdy my nejsme proti té,
vlastně proti umístění,
řekněme, zelené energetiky
a využívání,
ale jenom říkáme,
prostě nebyli jsme vlastně
nějak vyzváni ke konzultaci
v době, kdy se ty jednotlivé lokality
tady na území z Linského kraje řešili,
abychom mohli říct si,
tady ano, tady prosím ne,
protože to opravdu,
té lokalita je využívána občany
a vlastně způsobí to problém
a naopak problém v povolovacím procesu,
protože akcelerační zóny
prosím znamenají to,
že ten zhotovitel
v rámci stavebního řízení
nebude muset řešit proces EI,
ale jinak standardní proces
bude probíhat.
To znamená,
on nebude povinen pouze,
jako bude moci vynechat EI,
ale jinak ve standardním stavebním procesu
se dá silně očekávat,
že pokud to bude takto umístěno
nebo prostě opravdu v té těsné blízkosti,
jak je to tady návržené v těch Malenovicích,
tak tam bude velmi silný odpor
a prostě to vzhledem k tomu,
jak vnímáme asi všichni,
jak dlouho se tady snažíme získat
územní rozhodnutí
na propojení
dální CD 49
s komunikací 1,49
s tím, že jako tu naší část
o vpatu záležné,
když už 500 dní
nebo víc než skoro takská dva roky
řešíme odvolání ekologického spoluku
na podjato z Línského kraje,
tak prostě pokud to my naopak
se snažíme jít tou cestou,
že říkáme ano,
plně respektujeme tomu,
že to má vzniknout,
plně respektujeme nějaký úsled ten trend,
ať už s ním souhlasíme
nebo nesouhlasíme,
prostě takhle je to nastaveno,
ale proto prosím to dejme do lokality,
kde to bude moci reálně vzniknout
a ne, že se bude přetlačovat,
když to řeknu,
velký veřejný odpor.
Takže to je vlastně
ty naše debaty,
které se snažíme vzm ministerstvem
a uvidíme,
jak úspěšní budeme.
A já se přiznám,
že samozřejmě například
v některých jiných lokalitách,
mimozdým to také nezávidím,
protože ty větrníky,
ty současné generace,
to je vlastně větrník 250 metrů vysoký,
to už prostě samozřejmě
je trošku nějakým čem jiném
a tam ty debaty jsou samozřejmě
ještě o to intenzivnější.
Takže já si myslím,
že my tady chceme být
konstruktivním partnerem
v rámci té diskuze.
Problém je ten,
že jsme byli osloveni
až na konci,
kdy už těch změn
nebo ve výsledku těch debat
není už moc jakoby kde,
jak je vést.
A proto,
ačkoliv můžeme být konstruktivní,
tak prostě je otázkou,
co se nám podaří reálně prosadit.
Poprosím, Aleš Eduvka.
Tak já možná taky nějakou poznámku,
k tomu měl.
Já pro ten materiál samozřejmě
budu s klidným svědomím hlasovat.
Vnímám ho jakési vlastně
gesto naše učí
malinovickým občanům.
Nicméně myslím si,
že by bylo dobré
jakoby nějaký neklid
nebo nějaké emoce
trochu sklidnit.
Už jenom proto,
že vlastně Zlínský kraj
je oblast,
kde skutečně nejméně fouká
v celé republice.
Ve Zlínském kraji
fouká úplně nejméně.
Jako všude jinde fouká víc.
Myslím si,
že když to ta vláda
takhle stanovovala,
tak to primárně stanovovala
pro oblast
vlastně
severních chřibů,
to znamená
tam ty věžky,
morkovice a tady tohle všechno,
kde tam fakt fouká z téhane.
A podle mě,
tak aby se neřeklo,
tak tady hodil ještě
možná
jako západ z Líná.
Ale podle mě
jako
tam reálnost
stavby nějakého větrníku
tam v té oblasti
je velmi malá.
protože bych chtěl
fakt vidět
toho investora,
co by šel
do toho rizika
hádek
s nějakýma
třeba
vlastníkama
sousedních pozemků
a navíc
navíc vlastně
by vůbec nevěděl,
jestli mu to
tu investici něco vrátí,
protože tam prostě
nefouká tolik,
kolik by mělo.
Takže jako
myslím si,
že by bylo dobré
zachovat určitý klid.
Ano,
jenom
nám v těch Mladnovicích
je navržená
solární elektrárna,
několik ten větrník,
ten by tam vůbec
už jako opravdu
jako neměl smysl
a ten solár
je taky otázku
ta fotovoltaická elektrárna,
protože,
říkám,
je to z velké části
severní svách,
takže
těch ní víme,
že ty se staví z pravidla
ty fotovoltaická elektrárny
na svazích,
které jsou nakoněné jinam.
Ale to určitě
ještě tak pak
Jirka Robenek
všechno,
všechno věřím,
že ještě zhrne.
A poprosím tedy
náměstka
pana Wolfa.
Jmen taky ode mě.
Já si myslím,
že by bylo dobré
jako předkladatel
a navrhovatel
vůbec toho materiálu,
bych se k tomu taky vyjádřil.
Budu
na pana Dudáka reagovat.
Ono,
vy jste mluvil
o větrníkách původně.
Tady se jedná
o 50 hektarů
plochy,
kde bude
fotovoltaika
v podstatě na,
nebo je
zamýšlená fotovoltaika
na zelené půdě.
To je na louce,
části lesa,
je tam nějaká půtní cesta
ke Svaté vodě
v Malenovicích.
Myslím si,
že i samotná
ta směrnice,
která vlastně
říká ministerstvu,
kde by měla být
tady fotovoltaika,
popřípadě ty větrníky,
tak se baví,
že by to měly být
brownfieldy,
různé bývalé
těživní areály,
popřípadě
ta skládka,
která je v Kvítkovicích
docela kousek.
A naopak se má
vyhýbat
takovýmhle prostorům,
které jsou blízko
zástavby.
Tam je podmínka
nebo je tam nějaký
limit 500 metrů,
tady jsme možná
50 metrů od zástavby
v některých těch místech.
A zároveň
ta lokalita je
docela cená
i v oblasti
životního prostředí.
Odbor životního prostředí
tam už před nějakýma
10-12 rokama
měl v plánu
vyhlásit VKP,
aby to byla lokalita,
která nebude dotčena
nějakou zástavbou
nebo nějakýma změnama.
A teď se bavíme o tom,
že bychom ho kompletně
a 50 hektarů
není malá plocha
zastavili.
Takže proto
není to o tom,
že bychom nesouhlasili
i tak znít ten materiál,
že nesouhlasíme s tým,
aby se vybudovala někde
takováhle
fotovoltaická plantáž,
nebo nevím,
jak to nazvat,
ale nejsme
zajedno
s tým umístěním.
To je na tom místě
úplně špatně.
Takže to je za mě všechno.
Děkuji.
Mlžstvíme děkuji
za to upřesnění
a další zásí
den.
Já si myslím,
že celý problém
tady u toho
byl ten,
že ten postup byl,
jak říkal pan primátor,
přesně obrácený.
Nikdo se tady
v lokalitě neptal
na to,
jestli tady má být
nebo nemá být.
Já bych ocenil aktivitu
Jirky Robenka,
který to opravdu rozběhla
a všichni ostatní
jsme ho přidali.
A stejně tak jako
alež s klidným svědomím
tady budu hlasovat
pro to,
aby tato lokalita
z toho byla dána
pryč na drostanu.
To, že bychom se
bez zelené energie
obešli do budoucna
je naprostý nesmysl
a bez hledu na to,
co říká Evropská unie,
bez hledu na to,
jestli máme závazky
k Evropské unie
nebo nemáme,
ale prostě bez toho
to nepůjde.
Takže budeme muset
hledat cesty,
ale výrazně,
možná rozumnějším způsobem
využívat možností,
které dává nová technologie,
postupně s tím
takhle pracovat
a možná s větším
myslím,
netuším,
jak předcházející vláda
tyhle věci vymýšlela,
proč je dala,
ale jakým způsobem
to už asi nemá smysl
rozklíčovávat,
ale tady určitě
tohle nebyla zrovna
vzvolená lokalitá rozumě.
Proto to podpoříme.
Dobrá, množka děku.
Poprosím pana Juráše.
Dobrý den,
dámy a panové.
Ono už toho hodně
podstatného
u tohoto témata zaznělo.
Já drobně navážu,
dělám z toho dvě
takové vrstvy.
Hlavně voli kolegům z SPD,
pře na zastupita
z Tuzinského kraje
jsme slyšeli
tklivé příběhy
o ohrožování života
zdraví občanů
ultrazvukovými vlnami,
které vylizují
větrné elektrárny,
tak bych se k tomu
přeci jen vrátil.
Takže první vrstva.
Evropa není
energeticky soběstačná
a nikdy nebude.
Naše území
nám neposkytuje
dostatek nerostů,
minerálu,
nemáme zde
na ležiště ropy,
nejsme schopni sami
spalovat
fosilní paleva.
Jsme energeticky
závislá země,
musíme energii dovářet.
Stejně jako celá Evropa.
Proto máme tak velké problémy
v současné době,
kdy je uzavřen
hormonský průliv,
protože se nám nedostává
do Evropy
energetických zdrojů,
které potřebuje k tomu,
aby jsme obrazně řečeno
poháněli
kola naši průmyslové výroby,
topili naše byty
a měli se ve skrze dobře.
Evropská unie,
jestli toho vědoma je,
reaguje tím,
že říká jednotlivým státům,
prosím vás,
pojďme udělat,
co můžeme,
přetavme sluneční svit
a větrnou energii
na elektrickou energii,
která pohání
naše stroje.
My vám za to dáme,
na to dáme peníze.
Dáme vám peníze na to,
abyste si nemuseli
otravovat svůj vzduch
vypoužděním
spalování emisí z uhlí.
dáme vám peníze
na to,
abyste si nelikvidovali
životní prostředí
a dáme vám peníze
i na to,
abyste si neotravovali vodu
a zachovali
své životní prostředí
v lepším stavu,
než ve kterém
jste ho převzali
pro vaše budoucí generace.
Čili zmiňování
Evropské unie
na všech stranách
bych poprosil,
aby bylo korektní,
poctivé a férové.
To je záměr.
Otázka akceleračních zón
je otázka
naprosto druhá,
to znamená tam,
kde se mají umístěvat
zdroje obnovitelné energie.
V současné době
se bavíme o dvou
základních typových zdrojích,
větrná energie,
větrníky, jasně,
a fotovoltaická energie.
To znamená fotovoltaické panely,
které přetavují sluneční svít,
zjednodušeně řečeno
na elektrickou energii.
Teďka řešíme
konkrétní zónu
v Malenovicích.
My nejspíše
také podpoříme
to stanovisko,
byť a ta druhá vrstva
u tohohle detailu
spočívá v tom,
že ten připravený materiál
a jeho odůvodnění
obsahuje
zájemně si odporující závěry.
Vysvětlím.
Máme třeba bod jedna,
který říká,
že dle platného územního plánu
je předmětná akcelerační obrad
navržená jako
plocha zemědělská,
plocha smíšené
nezastavěného území.
Kdyby jsme zde umístili
akcelerační oblast,
cituju z materiálu,
tak budeme říkat,
že to má výrazný dopad
na krajný ráz,
kvalitu životního prostředí,
obytnost místa,
pohodu bydlení,
koncepční rozvoj města
v zemědělském území,
v nezastavitelné ploše.
Když to říká územní plán,
že takhle to tam fungovat
nikdy nebude,
tak proč z toho
dovozujeme závěry
k akcelerační zóně?
Zmiňujeme mimo jiné to,
že není to vhodné
z pohledu morfologie území.
Tomu rozumíme.
Má tam být fotovoltaika,
tak morfologie já si představuju tak,
že to není vhodné
pro umístění fotovoltaických panelů.
Asi tam je nějaká překážka.
A omezený energetický potenciál.
Tak tomu nerozumím.
Je to louka,
cvítí na to slunce,
tak mi někdo musí vysvětlit,
jestli omezený energetický potenciál
znamená,
že tam neumístím dostatek těch panelů,
nebo že tam nesvítí,
nebo je to v zákrytu,
nebo co se vlastně děje.
Čili já neříkám,
že nemá být respektováno všechno,
co zmínil třeba pan náměstek Wolf.
Ten řekl, hele,
je to dost blízko té zástavby,
takhle to úplně nechcem.
Jo, chceme,
aby to fungovalo jinak,
ale poprosil bych město,
aby když už dělá tu racionalizaci,
tak si dalo možná lepší práci
s těmi argumenty,
proč vlastně chce podpořit
ten záměr těch obyvatel.
A hlavně jsem tady
v takové zvláštní pozici,
čekal bych to,
ale pan Robenek ještě bude mluvit
o dostatních,
jako řekněme,
asi více liberálně orientovaných strán,
že se budou hlásit
opravou k obnovitelným zdrojům energie.
Děkuju.
Dobrá, děkuji.
A poprosím ještě pana Robenka.
Tak, děkuji za slovo.
Já se pokusím teď v krátkosti
stručně nastínit,
v jaké jsme aktuálně situaci.
My jsme kontaktovali
Ministerstvo pro místní rozvoj
s tím, že vidíme opravdu
tady tu lokalitu za nešťastně zvolenou,
ale zároveň jsme dodávali to,
že si uvědomujeme prostě,
že vyčlenění konkrétní zóny,
byť je to v našem katastru,
je potřebné
a že chceme najít nějaké jiné řešení.
Postupovali jsme tak,
že jsme prozkoumávali další plochy,
které splňují ty zásadní parametry
o kterých v rámci
tady tohoto zákona
ti lidé, kteří ty zóny vytyčovali,
stojí jako primární.
Týká se to především
té erodované půdy.
Když je tam vysoká míra té eroze,
tak je to základní ukazatel,
na základě kterého oni se rozhodují,
zda ano nebo ne.
My jsme se pokusili navrhnout
tři nějaké náhradní lokality,
ty jsme jim předložili
a v současné chvíli čekáme na to,
zda to bude možné nebo nebude.
Rozhodujícím faktorem,
protože celý tento proces
schvalování a navrhování
akceleračních zón je pod velkým
časovým tlakem,
tak rozhodujícím faktorem je v současné chvíli
to, zda ministerstvo
k navrženým náhradním akceleračním zónám
má k dispozici
zpracovanou seu,
jestli tam proběhl v tom jejich
přípravném procesu průzkum nebo neproběhl.
Pokud nikoliv,
tak ta šance na výměnu té zóny
je prakticky nulová.
Samozřejmě ta diskuze,
já rozumím tomu, na co narážíte,
se v řadě případů
ať už u těch větrných elektráren
a i u těch solárů zvrhává
k nějakým konspiračním teoriím a podobně.
Na druhou stranu to není úplně to,
co my bychom komunikovali,
ale říkáme, že
tady ta navržená konkrétní zóna
není opravdu hodně vybraná.
Asi bychom v této situaci
nebyli, ať už ve Zlíně nebo
v jiných obcích Zlínského kraje,
kdyby tady tomu vyčlenění
předcházela jakákoliv debata
se starosty nebo se zastupiteli
dotčených obcí.
Protože není to úplně tak
ani v těch diskuzích s těmi starosty,
já jsem z několika z nich mluvil,
že by měli nějaký zásadní,
principiální problém s tím,
že by u nich mělo něco vzniknout,
ale je to prostě problematika toho,
že to vzniká v místech,
kde ten kontakt s těmi obyvateli
prostě bude,
nebo v místech, které mají nějaký lokální
význam, ti lidé tam chodí
trávit volný čas na procházku,
je to vytížené prostě místo.
Tak samozřejmě potom dochází
k tady té, řekněme,
až hysterické reakci od společnosti.
Na druhou stranu, já musím říct,
že je trošku možná opodstatněná
ta hysterická reakce
a to v tom ohledu,
že to projednávání
tady tohoto záměru
obnovitelných zdrojů
je v neskutečné časové tisni.
Nechci tady rozebírat ty důvody,
proč je to v takové časové tisni,
ale jenom když se zamyslíme nad tím,
jakým způsobem tady například
je dlouhodobě zdržována
a rozporovaná dostavba dálnice,
co se kolem toho děje,
jak to projednávají soudy,
do jakého detailu se přeskoumává
výskyt živočíchů a podobně.
A potom to mám porovnat s tím,
jak je zpracována zpráva
o životním prostředí
v té lokalitě akceleračních zón,
tak si trošku klepu na hlavu,
protože je to opravdu
neskutečně neporovnatelné.
Tady se spěchá,
tady se přehlíží,
zatímco u dostavby dálnice,
byť je to nějaká liniová
strategická stavba,
tak se nám všechno protahuje
o spoustu let.
Takže za mě takto jenom v krátkosti.
Děkuji.
Dobrá, moc která děkuju
za to zhrnutí.
Poprosím ještě pan Skála.
Záměru, já to úplně nevím,
jak to tam je,
ale vím, že je to kus Malinovic,
který je obyvatelí oblíben,
chodí na procházky
a kdo jste byli na té demonstraci,
víte, že ten odpor tam byl velký.
A já osobně svůj názor říkám,
že toto patří na střechy,
máme hromadu volných střech,
parkovišť, betonových ploch
a my to furt dáváme do přírody.
Když jedete přes Otrokovice
kolem Barumu, tam důle,
tak Barum, tolik střech,
všecko prázdne
a letiště, sluneční elektrárny.
Teď je to na hlavu postavení.
Naši předci by nás museli hnat,
jak to je všecko k tomu.
Já jsem zásadně proti.
Dobrá, moc káme děkuji.
Poprosím pana náměstka Chalánka.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Já jenom krátká reakce na to,
co říká pan Juráž.
Ono je to opravdu tak,
jakože bez toho mixu se neobejdeme.
To je první věc.
Samozřejmě dobře stanovit ty pochy,
to je druhá věc.
Já bych řekl,
že každý musíme taky
trošku jako začít u sebe
a něco pro to udělat.
My samozřejmě město
vzorou kvolnosti,
myslím, že v úterý
kolaudujeme na
nazvo 800 kW
vlastně na Carportech.
Je to takovou unikátní stavbu
jako zase vlastně toho
našeho energetického sdružení.
Mimochodem, teď jsme schvalovali
další, když
schvalovali jsme další
přidělení peněz na upravy střech
16. a 17. a
Mateřská škola Kuty,
kde počítáme nějakých 200 kW.
Ale já chci jenom
využít ten kontrast.
Jestli pan Skála mluví o střechách.
Ta plocha je nastavená
na 50 MW.
50 MW.
Na těch střechách
to neuděláte.
Nehledě na to, že ty střechy
samozřejmě dneska nejsou už
ty historicky stavěné
jako postavené na to,
aby nesli tu zátěž,
aby ho hovalo všem těm parametrom.
Takže já souhlasím s tím,
když je to takové
v tuto chvíli
neúplně populární to říct,
ale my bez těch akceleračních zón
se neobejdeme.
získat toho mixu.
My je budeme muset dělat.
Můžeme se bavit o tom,
že by měly vznikat jindé,
za jiných podmínek,
v rámci jiné diskuze,
ale ještě bych řekl jednu věc
a s tím se tady setkáváme
všichni pořád.
To znamená,
my jsme poměrně silně
hustě zabydlené oblasti,
tím myslím Českou republiku,
takže ať když ten větrník
postavíte kdokoliv,
tak vždycky bude někdo,
komu to bude vadit.
A tady jde o to,
jak to vykompenzovat,
co těm lidem dát jako kompenzaci,
kde tu lokalitu vybrat,
ale to ústřední téma je,
my potřebujeme energetický mix
pro budoucnost
a ten mix prostě nemůže vzniknout
jen na střechách.
To není možný.
Dobrý, moc děkuji za to ukřesení
a poprosím ještě paní Pešatovou.
Dobrý den,
protože ta debata byla dlouhá,
tak já jsem se nějak rozpomněla
na nějakou historickou paralelu,
se kterou bych se s váma ráda podělila,
protože o těch akceleračních zónách
v podstatě jednali
už na začátku 20. století.
Možná, že některý z vás
si taky vzpomene na
jméno,
který ještě
před vznikem republiky
vlastně působil jako popularizátor
vysokého napětí
na našem území.
On opravdu
objížděl jednoho každého sedláka,
na jehož poli
měla být vystavený
ten stožár pro rozvoj vysokého napětí
a vysvětloval,
proč je to důležité.
A z toho my čerpáme
o sto let později.
Takže
tato paralela v podstatě říká,
máme tady nějaké akcelerační zóny,
víme,
že potřebujeme energii
a budeme muset si vzájemně
vysvětlit,
jaký přínos to má
pro období za sto let po nás.
Já moc krát děkuju
a poprosím pana Lacinu.
Můžu prosím vás,
že já plně souhlasím s tím,
co tady řekl pan doktor Uráš.
Bez obnovitelných energetických zdraví
už se prostě neobejdeme.
Já mám ale pocit
v tomto případě,
že někdo z ministerstva
pro místní rozvoj
se podíval na mapu
a udělal tam kolečko.
Podle mě morfologicky,
když to vejmeme,
pane doktoré,
morfologicky,
mě trošku,
to voltojíka zajímá,
je to takový trošku koníček.
Morfologicky,
je to severní stráň,
za stěň na hřebeném
a pokud je mi znám
a učil jsem se dobře ve škole,
tak 21. prosince
slunce nad obzorem
v České republice
je 13 stupňů.
A i hluchá Tereza z Elhoty ví,
že nejvíc energetiky
potřebujeme v zimě.
A tato fotovoltaická elektra
na tomto místě v zimě,
pokud nebudu mít nulový výkon,
tak minimální.
Ještě si porovnejme,
že zabereme 50 hektarů
severního svahu,
který bude minimálně výkonný v zimě,
v létě budeme mít problém
s blackoutama.
A když porovnáme větrnou
nebo větrnou energii
a fotovoltaickou,
tak dneska menší větrník
je 250 kW,
velký větrník je 500 kW.
Větrník, to znamená
jeden 500 kW větrník
nám ubere prakticky
půl hektaru prostoru
a to s výkonem,
který je 500 kW,
když fouká.
Já si myslím,
že na Hřebených,
někde úplně mimo obce
a mimo tohle fouká dost,
aspoň teda
já mám dlouhodobě
nějaké,
toto jezdím na Javorníky
a mě tam fučí kolem
chalupy furt teda.
Ale samozřejmě
to je hloupost,
když to takhle řeknu,
je potřeba to změřit.
Já si myslím,
že tady nikdo,
nikdo v těch Malenovicích
neudělal to,
že tam udělal nějaké
měření slunečního svitu,
vstínění,
dopad na Severním zvahu.
A podle mě je to
absolutně nevhodně zvolená lokalita.
Ne proto,
jestli je to takové,
nebo makové,
nebo rozvojové,
nebo nerozvojové,
ale morfologicky
absolutně nevhodné.
Děkuji.
Dobrá, moc káme děkuji.
Poprosím ještě pana Dudáka.
Já děkuji ještě za slovo.
Opravdu se omlouvám,
že všechny už asi prudím,
ale já bych si moc přál
a moc děkuji
za vystoupení pana Robenka,
kdybychom byli schopni
a ochotní udělat
nějaké usnesení,
nějaký statement
v rámci zastupitelstva,
že jsme příznivci
zelené energetiky,
že hledáte ty jiné
akcelé místa
pro nějaký development
obnovitelných zdrojů.
A ta moje diskuze
vůbec neměla být
spojená s tímhle bodem.
To je opravdu jenom
jakási úvaha,
která by měla
trošku vést
ke změně myšlení
veřejnosti,
abychom prostě měli
v budoucnu levnou energii
nebo vůbec nějakou
v daleké budoucnosti.
A já mám jenom pocit
a bojím se,
aby to někdo takhle
neprezentoval,
že my tímhle usnesením
a nějakou,
já nemám sociální sítě,
ale dovedu si představit,
předtím,
ale toto je další cesta
k tomu,
jak se obnovitelným energím
dají házet klacky pod nohy
a dělat trošku dezinformace.
Čili, prosím,
pane Robenku
nebo pane primátore,
zvažte,
to, co jste řekli,
jestli umíte
nějakou formou
prezentovat
i třeba v tom
skvělém magazinu,
jak tady byl zmíněn,
tentokrát mi fakt
nebude vadit,
že tam bude
tolik vašich fotek,
obličejů.
A jenom to prostě
veřejnosti
takhle nějakou
nenucenou formou
z fakty
dát,
že to není o tom,
že odmítáme oze,
ale o tom,
že odmítáme
prostě špatné rozhodnutí
primárního záměru.
Určitě s vámi
souhlasím.
My jsme otevření
od začátku,
co kolem toho
nějakým zůstom vznikla,
ta hysterie se to objevilo,
tak my se snažíme
postupovat opravdu
v té míře
a i v těch tiskových zprávách
se snažíme informovat
o tom,
že nejsme,
nebo snažíme se,
aby to nevyznělo,
že my jsme proti
zelené energii
nebo obecně,
že jsme proti tomu
jako z principu,
ale o tom,
že opravdu rozporujeme
tu výběr té lokality,
protože,
tak jak tady jste dneska
slyšeli z více do názorů,
ono to prostě nedává
úplně logiku,
zhrvat toto umístění.
Na druhou stranu
ten problém
je pak ten časový,
kdy my se snažíme
být konstruktivním partnerem
a dostáváme se
do časového presu
nebo respektujete
navrhotovat
v časovém presu
a on vlastně
je otázkou,
do jaké míry
bude schopen
akceptovat
konstruktivní jednání
anebo bude muset
vlastně reagovat
na to,
aby splnil
to, co má zadáno,
protože prostě
ten časový pres
už je pro něho
na to jich velký.
Takže určitě
my nechceme,
nechceme určitě dělat
jakoukoliv retoriku,
že zelená energie
je špatně,
nemyslíme si to,
ale tady jenom řešíme,
že ta lokalita
je za nás špatně vybraná
a hledáme cesty,
jak konstruktivně najít
jakouby lokalitu jinou,
protože jsme si vědomi toho,
že ta zelená energie
prostě je,
je do budoucna cestou
a neoběděme se bez ní.
Prosím ještě
Jirku Robenka.
Já si musím
ještě jednu věc tady říct,
když jsem to říkat nechtěl původně.
Řeknu to,
platí to i na mě samozřejmě.
Tak jak tady sedíme,
tak se domnívám,
že této problematice
pořádně a do detailu
v podstatě nikdo z nás nerozumí.
Do takového detailu,
abychom byli schopni
reflektovat některé ty připomínky,
které se v té diskuzi objevují.
A bylo by dobré
s tím i tak pracovat,
že samozřejmě máme na to nějaký názor,
ale já sám si uvědomuji,
že v tom jako těžce plavu
spoustu věcí si musím dohledávat,
ujasňovat,
jak to je doopravdy.
Takže ta diskuze,
jakým způsobem
pohodně vyčlenovat ty zóny,
do jaké míry se poprat
s těmi obnovitelnými zdroji
v celkovém českém řešení,
ta tady by v podstatě
probíhat neměla.
To bychom měli nechat opravdu
na ty odborníky,
na energetiku.
Ale chtěl jsem doplnit
jednu věc,
takovou spíš prozbu
na vás všechny,
protože každý
má nějaké zástupce
v Praze
nebo má nějaké
prostě kontakty
mezi těmi odborníky.
Zkusme napravit
jednu věc,
která se v té České republice
nestihla.
Tady padlo,
že Německou
na těch obnovitelných zdrojích
pracuje dlouhodobě,
mají samozřejmě
větší podíl na trhu,
ale oni postupovali
trošku jinak
a myslím si,
že i pro tu veřejnost
to bylo přijatelnější.
Oni v první fázi
v podstatě udělali
velmi dobrou
detailní
v podstatě dokumentaci
pro to i legislativu,
jakým způsobem
budovat obnovitelné zdroje
na znehodnocené půdě,
jakým způsobem
využít energetiku
tohoto typu
na skládkách,
v místech,
kde probíhala
povrchová těžba.
U nás ta možnost
sice také je
něco takového realizovat,
ale není legislativně ošetřená,
není do detailu připravená.
A je to i jeden z důvodů,
kdy u nás ten proces
za mě je opačný
a špatný,
kdy pokud v tom Německu
probíhalo využití
těch povrchových dolů
a podobně,
tak samozřejmě ta veřejnost viděla,
že teda dobře,
nejdřív využíváme
tu znehodnocenou půdu,
potom hledáme lokality,
které nejsou třeba zatížené
pobytem lidí ve volném čase,
tam to umistňujeme.
Přesto i to Německo
samozřejmě čelí
nějakému náporu
a odporu veřejnosti,
když se tady ty lokality vyčlenňují.
Ale dokázalo se na to
legislativně opravdu lépe připravit,
než to bylo v našem případě.
Takže to je všechno.
Mocka děkuju za to doplnění.
Níkdo další se do diskuze nehlásí
a já tady nechám hlasovat
o tomto materiál číslo 21.
Myslím, že ta diskuze byla obsáhla
a jsme si všichni vědomi toho,
že to není,
že bychom odmítali z energetiku,
ale že opravdu tady toto místo vnímáme,
že je vybráno špatně.
Pro 36.
Materiál číslo 21 nebyl přijat.
Tímto jsme vyčerpali veškeré body,
které jsme měli dneska na programu
k hlasování.
Máte ještě přiloženy
čtyři informační materiály
a já bych chtěl tímto
otevřit diskuzi.
Poprosím pana Pášmu.
Vážený pane primátore,
vážení kolegové,
dobré dopoledne.
Já mám připraveno krátké okénko
o čtyřech tématech,
z nichž na konci zazní téma,
ke kterému se možná budete chtít
vyjádřit i vě ostatní.
Doufám, že ano.
První téma je festival
Jeden svět ve Zlíně,
který jsme uspořádali
s mou naziskovou organizací v Dubnu.
Myslím, že jsem vás zazval.
Nemyslím si, že jste všichni přišli,
ale to nevadí.
Přijdete příštím ročníku.
Já bych chtěl moc poděkovat
městu Zlínu Vedení
za spolupráci.
Děkuji panu primátorovi
i paní náměstkyni Hladíkové.
Odboru školství bych chtěl poděkovat.
Chtěl bych poděkovat živému Zlínu.
Byl to úspěšný festival,
který je lidskoprávní
a který má program pro školní mládež,
jakož i pro celou širou veřejnost.
Děkuji za krásné vystoupení
panu Robenkovi
a tímto tedy mu děkuji
i za jeho práci
pro Ukrajinu,
o které se málo ví mimochodem.
Příští ročník proběhne
v březnu roku 2027
a už teď vás všechny srdečně zvu.
Zvu vás jako občany,
jako nejen jako zastupitele,
takže kdyby jste náhodou
nebo kdybychom náhodou
někdo nebyli zvolení,
tak samozřejmě i tak
máte dveře doširoka otevřené.
Druhé téma je velice krátké
a jmenuje se Záhony.
Zlín nám upět krásně rozkvetl,
měští zahradníci
udělali skvělou práci,
já bych jim za to chtěl poděkovat.
Vy jim jako vedení města
určitě děkujete,
ale vím, děkujete vlastně jako šéfové,
já jim děkuji jako občan
a chtěl bych jim tímto vzkázat,
že si toho všímáme
a že je to velice, velice krásné,
kež bychom to mohli dělat i v budoucnu
z finančních důvodů.
Třetí téma je také velice krásné.
Děkuji za možnost,
on je to vlastně takové děkovací okénko,
že je dneska.
Děkuji za možnost zúčastnit se
milého setkání s panem Reinholdem Messnerem.
Bylo to prima, bylo to hezké,
skutečně inspirativní.
Jediná možná poznámečka
by byla k technickému zajištění
tohoto eventu,
kdy jsme možná
pozapomněli na to,
že pan Messner už je starší pán
a mluví tiše.
A ne všichni v sále
asi úplně dobře slyšeli,
co říká.
Tak to je jenom taková poznámka
pro inspiraci,
pro zlepšení případů.
Ne, protože se může stát,
že třeba nás navštíví taky někdo významný
i v budoucnu, že?
A budeme chtít tady s ním hovořit
a budeme ho chtít slyšet,
tak abychom na to byli technicky připraveni.
Čtvrté téma
a poslední je hokej.
Já myslím, že bychom se asi k tomu měli vrátit,
protože když jsme o hokeji mluvili naposledy,
tak jsme byli v hruzostrašné situaci
a pak se stalo něco velice pozorohodného.
Myslím, že hokejisti povstali jako Fénix z Popela
a nakonec nám jako městu určitě ostudu neudělali.
Takže bych možná asi vás tímto vyzval,
jestli někdo k tomu chcete něco říct.
Já si myslím, že tomu pomohlo i to krylování,
že představitelů hokejistů,
že vlastně za to můžeme my,
že jsme hráli to finále.
Já jsem to pozorně sledoval,
navštivoval jsem zimní stadionem.
Opravdu si myslím, že se nemáme za co stydět
a že se z té sezony vlastně můžu říct,
vybruslilo velice dobře.
Tak kdybyste někdo chtěli navázat na hokej
nebo na cokoliv jsem řekl,
tak samozřejmě potěšení na mé straně.
Nejte hezké jarní dny
a děkuji za pozornost.
Já moc kde děkuji za všechny ty pochvaly,
ty inspirativní poznatky.
Já jsem velice rád,
že ten hokej vnímáte teďka tak pozitivně
a věřím tomu,
že ho budete vnímat stejně tak pozitivně
během ještě tohoto vhodobního období,
kdy si určitě přijdeme pro finance,
protože ten rok kalendární
rozhodně nevyšel v nule.
Takže tím já nám předesílám,
že s něčím tady určitě budeme muset přijít
a já budu chtít, aby vedení hokeje udělal seminář
pro vás, pro všechny, aby vám zdůvodnilo,
co se vlastně odehrálo
a co tam je dlouhodobě v rámci financování
tady této společnosti
ať to všichni navnímáme
a nějakým způsobem potom
budeme muset zareagovat
v rámci zastupitelstva,
protože samozřejmě to,
že ta sezóna byla komplikovaná,
to jsme si tu říkali,
od zraněných hráčů a podobně,
což znamenalo zase navýšení rozpočtu
na ten hrácký kádr,
ale ve výsledku si můžeme tady plácat po zádech,
že jak bylo řečeno,
dopadlo to asi velmi pozitivně
proti tomu, jak to vypadalo.
My jsme ještě tři kola
nebo čtyři kola před koncem řešili,
jestli zase vstoupíme,
takže v tu danou chvíli si myslím,
že jsem rád asi za nás, za všechny,
že to dopadlo tímto způsobem,
ale každopádně to sebou něco neslo
a zcela otevřeně to playoff
to finančně nezachránilo,
takže v tu danou chvíli
sice to částečně pomohlo,
ale já vám říkám předem,
že samozřejmě má to i nějaké své
negativní, nebo by řekl nebeselé,
nebeselé úskalí
a za mě se musí užívat
hlavně kroky k tomu,
abych se tady nemusel
chodit na zastupitelstvo,
dáříc každý rok s nějakým takovýmto
systémem rozpočtovým,
takže tam spíš se musí něco nastavit
ještě koncepčně dál
a každopádně to jenom avizu předem,
že něco rozhodně přijde
a myslím si, že během 14 týdnů
dostanete nějakou pozvánku na seminář,
ještě to právě řešíme
a musíme si taky říct, jaké varianty jsou
a v jakých částkách,
takže to spíš jenom za mě.
A moc za to děkuju.
Nechtěl jsem to takto zhodit
zase tu do té ponuré nálady,
ale prostě to je bohužel,
bohužel je to realita.
Poprosím, pane Juráše.
Já taky nechci už dneska zdažovat
a navážu na Martina
s tím mírně laskavým humorem.
Už jsem nechtěl u těch bodů
provozních modelů to větvit,
ale inspirovala mě k tomu Katka Pešatová.
A my bychom opravdu velmi zdvořilé požádali,
aby ty provozní modely
byly vždycky připojovány k těm materiálům,
aby jsme si nepřipadali,
jak Aneška Jechová ve filmu Kulový blésk,
jak se jde ptát k rodině Abrahama
a máte sklep
a mohla bych ho vidět.
Bylo by toho možná přivětivější pro nás.
Já moc děkujem.
Poprosím, pane Jandu.
Děkuji, pane primátore,
já bych taktež nedat příliš zdržoval,
ale pan Pašman by trošku předběhl
a děkuji za to samozřejmě,
protože to grillování bylo hlavně z mé strany,
jestli si vzpomínáte.
A chci říct, že ta radost je tak trošku na půl.
A myslím si, že ten hlavní podíl
na tom skutečně měl,
který v podstatě dokázal to,
co, jak jsem říkal,
možná nedokáže ani
sestavit tým po
sladit ho a dostat se do nějaké fáze.
A on to dokázal.
On dokázal z posledního místa nemožné.
A možná, když by stalo za to se podívat
do statistik,
jsme se dostali do finále,
takže za mě opravdu
klobouk dolů.
A ten výsledek závěrečný byl
skvělý, nicméně k té ekonomice
říkám si, co by se ještě muselo stát,
aby ta ekonomika teda
v daném momentě byla
v těch lepších číslech,
než v kterých to je.
A ta druhá polovina je ta,
že já jsem tady mimo jiné
grilovali a u toho bych zůstal.
Protože, jak jistě víte,
obrátil se teda na mě spoustu rodičů,
já to tady dneska nechci nějak zásadně
prezentovat, pan primátor říkal,
že k tomu bude jistila jistě nějaký seminář.
Nicméně junorka nám spadla.
Je to po 63 letech.
To znamená 63 let
ty generace hokejistů,
já ji nechci všechny jmenovat,
proč bych určitě na některé zapomněl.
Po 63 letech nám spadla junorka,
což je, bych řekl,
ta líheň a to základno,
ta mládež, kde bychom měli věnovat
tu pozornost, ty zdroje.
A to bohužel se nepodařilo
a nepodařilo se to podvedení,
který v daném momentě si myslím,
že by měl z toho vyvodit
skutečně tých závěry,
na které jsem minule již upozorňoval.
Jenom pro takovou zajímavosti
rodiče mi říkají,
že on neměl, pardon,
když to tak dneska tady řeknu,
ani ty koule,
aby na závěr té sezóny
se s nimi sešel,
pokud to ještě neudělá.
To znamená,
že to, co se vždycky udělalo
s těmi rodiči,
vyhodnotila se ta soutěž.
Řeklo se,
jak to bude pokračovat dál,
tak to se nestalo.
Z těch padesátích,
mám nít dobrou informací,
osmi kluků,
kteří jsou v tom dorostu,
tak nám 33 odešlo.
Odešlo nám někde jinde.
Mnohdy to byly i naši lidé,
naši odchovanci,
kteří v daném momentě
se telefonicky dozvěděli,
že už se s nimi klub nepočítá.
Kdyby to bylo jeden, dva, deset,
rozumím,
ale 33 děti nám odešlo.
To znamená,
že ta situace v té mládeži
je docela tragická.
Já ji nechci analyzovat,
nejsem na to,
prosím, odborník.
Byl jsem požádán,
abych tu situaci
nějakým způsobem odprezentoval,
že fajn,
Maxalika dopadla,
jak dopadla, dobře.
Ale u té mládeže
a u té výchovy,
kde dáváme nemalé množství peněz,
a měli bychom dávat
poměrně velké prostředky,
protože očekáváme,
že z těch mladých
nám něco vyroste,
že je prostě vychováme,
tak tady nám to vůbec nefunguje.
Ta situace mezi těmi rodiči,
kteří do toho dávají zdroje,
kteří do toho dávají své úsilí,
jední z mála,
tady v tom regionu platí,
v okolí se takové částky neplatí,
ročně 18-19 tisíc
za nějaké poplatky,
opět nechci to rozebírat.
V každém případě
by bylo dobře,
kdyby se s těmi mládežníky
někdo sešel,
tak jak to historicky dělávali.
A aby ti rodiče měli možnost,
oni jsou ti,
kteří tam vodí ti děti,
kteří za ně svým způsobem ručí
a taky fandí,
aby ty děti ten sport dělali,
tak aby měli tu možnost
si s tím vedením promluvit.
Mám informace,
že skutečně přístup je tragický.
O těch věcích,
o kterých jsme tady mluvili v Dubnu,
teda vůnoru,
promiňte nás,
stejně nikdo neinformoval,
takže to už jsou jenom otázka,
a jak jsou oceněni takový manažeři,
kteří odvedli takovou práci,
která prostě nedopadla dobře,
ale je to napříč,
tam je 13 dům stev,
z toho dvě dopadly,
řekněme tomu nějak přijatelně,
zbytek nebyl v dobré kondici.
Ale ať nemluvím jenom
o negativních věcech,
chtěl jsem s dovolením říct,
tak též jinou záležitost,
měli jsme seckání s panem primátorem,
místní část ní vyvršavá,
a chtěl jsem poděkovat za přístupy,
které jsou ať už z hlediska odboru zeleně,
který tam řeší na Nivách,
směr k UNOBARu,
nějaké záležitosti dává to do pořádku,
technické služby dávají do pořádku,
komunikaci, jak si stěžovali občané,
takže za to jsem chtěl
samozřejmě velmi poděkovat.
Upozorňoval jsem v minulosti
na havarní stav mostu na Vršavě,
prosím, k našim sportovištím.
Vím, že jsem dostal nějaký projekt,
kdy to budeme chystat,
kdy to budeme dělat,
prosím vás, ta situace je tam tak špatná,
že v podstatě ten most za mě
v této fázi je pro ty občany,
dneska, když si tam projedete,
nebezpečný.
My jsme tam dali vyloženě nějaké plotny,
tak buď to zaplotnujme celé,
nebo to zavřeme,
ale ta situace,
běžte se tam někdo podívat,
je neúnosná.
Ten most opravdu je dneska
už v havarním stavu
a v nedobré kondici.
Chtěl bych, byl bych rád,
kdyby se s tím něco, prosím, udělalo.
Děkuji.
Začnu od konce,
co se týká mostu,
já jsem to sám urgoval
na odboru dopravy,
že to je v šíleném stavu
8.6. tuším,
má dojít k jednomu dní,
kdy to bude celý den uzavřeno,
tento most,
aby se dal kompletně do pořádku,
osměň do té míry,
do které to jde.
Je to komunikováno
se zástupci těch sportovních klubů,
aby věděli,
že ten den prostě se tam
nikdo moc nedostane.
Takže 8.6. má podběhnout doprava.
Co se týká hokeje,
já se přiznám,
že já tady slyším už,
já bych byl strašně rád možná,
že než se tady exibovat
na zastupitelstvu,
že to dělá kdokoliv,
tak možná si sedněte s těmi lidmi
a začněte se bavit
o té informace,
ať máte ty informace,
co se tam děje,
protože například,
co se týká té mládeže,
a to je obecně strategické
rozhodnutí toho klubu,
případně,
že my ve spolku
z pozice města,
prosím, nemáme nic.
Město ve spolku nemá nic,
to si pojďme říct otevřeně.
To znamená,
do pozice města z jiná,
ano, můžeme se bavit,
že tam posíláme
finanční prostředky na činnost,
ty mají standardní vzorec,
jako každý jiný,
to znamená,
spolek je nezávislý,
co se týká
nějakého nařízení města.
Každopádně je
na rozhodnutí spolku,
na strategickém rozhodnutí,
jestli chce dělat,
tady řekněme,
výkonnostní sport
a držet si nejvyšší ligy,
a nebo chce hrát
se zlínskými dětmi.
Současný stav
nelze řešit
více méně tímto způsobem,
který byl slučitelný,
protože vzhledem tomu,
jak se chovají
ostatní kluby,
které výchovu mládeže
dá říct nemají
nebo jim mají špatnou,
pak dojedou do Zlína.
V současné době
prosím nás oslovují děti
ve věku,
v sedmé tříde,
že ve věku 12 let.
12 leté děti
nám aktuálně různě
přetahují ostatní kluby.
Děti,
myslím,
to jsou u šestnáctky
a podobně,
tak kteří jsou
v současné době
v reprezentaci,
tak každý z nich
má 11 nabídek,
aby přešel někam jinam.
11 nabídek
každý z těch klubů.
S tím,
že řešíte,
že když nejsou pod smlouvou,
tak s vás
k nepochopení
vícemě všech klubů,
kromě asi extraligových,
udělal,
já tomu říkám,
šťastný květen,
kdy na celý měsíc
zrušil tabulky.
To znamená,
aktuálně vám řeší,
tam vám dokoliv dojede
a z každé kategorie
vám může sebrat
až tři hráče
a to s těmáme vezme.
Bez jakékoliv nároků
pro ten klub,
který je vychoval.
Tož asi není taky úplně správně.
Takže to jsou věci,
chcete,
jmenuji se tam potýkají
dnes a denně
a z těla otevřeně,
pokud se řešila
například ta juniorka,
tady se podíváte
na hráče,
odkud jsou,
tak zjistíte,
že my v juniorkce
nemáme hráče z Lotyška,
nemáme hráče z Ukrajiny,
nemáme hráče z jiných
takovýchto východnějších zemí
a když se podíváte
do jiných klubů,
kteří takto hrajou,
tak buď mají vzkoupené
ty hráče
od dorostu
z devítky
z jiných klubů,
ať už od nás
nebo od jinut,
nebo větkařiších,
které jsou to kluby
a potom
samozřejmě
poráží
ty ostatní,
protože prostě
místo, aby vychovávali,
tak v určitém věku
skupují
a skupují čím dál rychleji
nebo čím dál dříve.
Pak je výsledek ten,
že vy samozřejmě
nemáte v každé kategorii
10 talentů,
staráť, že tam máte jednoho
a v tu danou chvíli,
když vám 4-4 hráči odejdou,
tak vlastně hrajete
rási s nějakým
průměrným týmem,
pokud ho nechcete obohatit
o nějakého hráče
mimo Zlínského.
V současné době
byla retorika
vedení
hokejového spolku
dlouhodobě,
že se hrajou
Zlínské děti
s tím,
že toto se říká i rodičům
a když řeknete rodičům
dobrý, tak jestli chcete být,
abychom jim byli lepší,
tak není problém,
my teda zkusíme někoho přivést,
ale další 6 lidí,
6 dětí od vás tady posadíme
nebo pošleme do nějakého jiného klubu
nebo si najděte, co chcete,
tak v tu danou chvíli
se to samozřejmě nelíbí.
Takže
ono to má prostě své pro a proti,
je to potřeba
si způsobem nějakým vyhodnocovat,
za mě to mají vyhnocovat lidé,
kteří jsou tam na denní bázi
a znají to prostředí,
ví, co se na svazu chystá
a jestli si někdo myslí,
že pro kohokoliv je příjemné,
že se jenůraka sestoupila
v tom klubu,
tak asi není,
ale já mám pocit,
že kudy chodím,
tak to muslyším různá jména,
koho máme vyhodit
a vyhodit někoho
je strašně jednoduché
většinou,
takže se to musí vmezit zákona,
ale je potřeba věci
taky řešit koncepčně
a dlouhodobě
a to, že se někde
jeden rok něco nepodaří,
neznamená,
že je všechno špatně.
Stačí se podívat
na výsledky jiných kategorii
v té mládeži
a zjistíte,
že to zase tak špatné není
a teďka řeší,
že na základě toho,
že jeden rok
juniorka nepovedla
a se stoupila,
tak vyhodím tam,
kdo je za to nejvýše
zodpovědný,
bez ohledu na to,
jakým způsobem
hrajou ostatní kategorie,
je za mě velice krátko zraké
a myslím si,
že pokud tady někdo
z tyto věci řešit,
tak bych poprosil,
ať se napřed potká
opravdu s těmi lidmi,
zjistí si informace,
ať potom dáváme
ty relevantní
nebo prosím kdokoliv,
kdykoliv napište mě
nebo vedení toho klubu
a požádajte oskusku,
ať se s nimi potkáte,
ať se pak zbytečně
nešíří nějaké
dezinformace
a myšlenkové pochody,
které se načerpávají
v různých jiných situacích.
To jenom spíš za mě.
Já si myslím,
že se v tom,
že jsme to tady řešili
už dlouhodobě
a myslím si,
že i pro to,
když ten bude ten seminář,
tak určitě jste budete
schopni zeptat na cokoliv.
Jinak ten seminář
prostě bude k Ačku.
Tomovějme to,
co řešíme,
kde jsme ze 79% spoluvlastník
a samozřejmě
na nás dopadá
taky ta ekonomika.
Díky tomu.
Poprosím paní Pešatovou.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Za mě to bude také
o dětech
a také o mladé generaci,
protože jste si určitě všimli,
že začal velký festival,
který se jmenuje ZUŠ Open
a v rámci tohoto festivalu
se prezentují i z Línské ZUŠky
svým tradičním festivalem
ZUŠka,
respektive už zas ZUŠ
a v neděli mají velký koncert
v kongresovém centru,
tak bych ho doporučila
vaší pozornosti,
protože právě spolupráce
tří základních uměleckých škol
ze Zlína
byla vlastně jedním
z inspiračních zdrojů vzniku
celé prezentace
ZUŠek v republice.
A určitě pro vás taky
nebude nová informace,
že základní umělecké školy
jsou tak výjimečným aspektem
České, respektive i Slovenské republiky,
protože si je dělíme mezi sebe,
že aspirují na seznam
nemateriálního kulturního dědictví.
A v širším vzdělávacím procesu
mají určitě svoji nezastupitelnou roli,
protože doplňují školní výuku,
oskušenost, která není jenom vědomostní,
ale především osobností.
Právě tady se děti naučí
naslouchat sobě a druhým.
A učí se vytrvalosti.
Protože dohrát
skladbu dokonce
znamená zvládnout
jeden každý takt.
Dobrá, moc krát děkuju.
To diskuze se někdo další nehlásí,
takže já vám moc krát děkuju všem
za konstruktivní jednání zastupitelstva.
Velice si toho vážím
a věřím tomu, že to udržíme
i na těch zbylých dvou zastupitelstv,
které se budou stále blížit
k volbám.
A chtělím vám všem popřádat,
máte pěkný zbytek dne
a pokud cokoliv potřebujete,
tak se nebojte ozvat.
Ať ty informace se radši předáváme
průběžně
a nečerpáme jenom tady veřejné zastupitelství.
Moc krát všem děkuju.